proper search engine optimization or seo
can make or break your website it can
put your website on top of everyone's
mind or let it be forgotten on the 10th
page of the google search results on
that note hi guys welcome to this
complete seo tutorial by simply learn in
this video we'll be covering some of the
most important concepts related to
search engine optimization we'll talk
about keyword research google analytics
google tag manager how you can rank
number one on google and youtube how to
increase youtube subscribers how to get
traffic to your website some popular seo
tools and finally some seo tips and
tricks first off we'll have an
introduction to seo by our instructors
robin matt welcome my name is rob
sanders i'm a course instructor at
simply learn today we're going to talk
about why you would want to rank using
seo and seo is search engine
optimization also known as organic
search you also may as hear us say
organic listings where we're going to
talk a little bit about why you'd want
to rank your website in organic search
okay what is search engine optimization
then we're going to follow that up with
how does google rank websites so why
does it rank one website over another
and how do we get our website to rank
number one then we're going to talk
about the different types of seo or
search engine optimization techniques so
you can get your website ranked number
one and then we're gonna finish that off
with the do's and don'ts of seo so let's
get right to it and talk about why seo
so we're gonna use a basic example and
let's just say you have a blog you're a
food blogger you're passionate about
food and your niche is ice cream and
let's just say you have a lot of ice
cream recipes you want to get traffic to
your blog you want people to read your
blog and you're curious why am i not
ranking for my blog
why when people type in ice cream
recipes and say google my blog posts
don't appear at the top of organic
rankings and there's a number of reasons
why you wouldn't be ranked for your blog
post or your ice cream recipes and the
main reason would be your competitors so
there could be somebody else out there
who is also passionate about ice cream
and has been blogging a long longer than
you when they have more content and more
blog posts and more pages for google to
rank so that's usually the number one
reason the other reason is improper
usage of keywords and we're going to
talk a little bit or it's actually a lot
more about you know keyword usage in
your content so what kind of keywords do
you want to rank for that's really what
we're talking about when we talk about
usage of keywords what keywords do you
want to rank for and how do we work
those keywords into the content another
reason is port link building practices
and really that means our other blog
posts or other websites linking to you
also are you linking to other pages on
your website and so it's all about link
building and with link building it's
internal linking so are we linking from
one blog post to another and it's
external linking are other websites of
high quality linking to us and so that's
what we talk about when we talk about
link building and then another reason is
web page load time so you could be
running your blog post on say wordpress
for example and your blog post isn't
loading fast enough well if you look at
it this way think about it if you're
google would you really want to rank a
website or blog post in this example
number one on google rankings if that
particular page loaded very slow no you
wouldn't because when somebody clicked
on that link in organic search and went
to your website they're going to have a
bad experience because the page is going
to load slow so google doesn't want
their users to have a bad experience you
don't want your users to have a bad
experience and so that's why web page
load time is a critical factor for
ranking so we need to make sure that our
web pages load fast and then your user
experience is not good enough so
google again based on my example about
the web page load time google wants
people to have a good experience when
they go from their search engine to your
website and there's a lot at play there
specifically web page load time but also
you know google doesn't want any spam
content google doesn't want any pop-ups
or overbearing ads on the web page they
want people to are searching for
something in particular let's just say
ice cream recipes and they want to find
a relevant website that has ice cream
recipes they want to be able to click on
that link and read some good content
about ice cream recipes it's that simple
and that's really what google's trying
to create in their environment and
that's you as an end user as a website
owner you want your users to have a good
experience and then last but not least
your website is the indexed by mistake
and really what we mean is the indexed
is google needs to be able to index all
the pages on your website so if you have
a blog with a hundred recipes you want
google to have access to all 100 recipes
so we're going to talk a little bit
later about how to get your pages ranked
or indexed on google organic search so
let's move on to what is seo so sticking
with our ice cream blog theme really seo
search engine optimization really is the
practice of increasing your pages that
google has indexed up the rankings so
the end result is we want all our pages
to be ranked number one for particular
keywords
so if you want to be ranked for ice
cream recipes well there's certain
things you need to do so that's
generally how it works we need to apply
search engine optimization to increase a
page for keyword we want to be found for
so let me give you an example so let's
just say there's a hundred students that
participated in an essay competition and
so the competition in this particular
case is evaluated on the basis of is the
content relevant are they using suitable
titles for their essay do they have
structure when they're participating in
this essay or talking about the essay
and do they have a suitable synopsis and
is the content neat and readable these
seem all logical for an essay
competition well guess what they seem
logical for seo because that's exactly
how seo works it's exactly all those
points i just may mention about
structure logic readability organization
title all those things are what's
important in seo and so we need relevant
content we need titles for our pages
google needs to be able to see structure
we need to have synopsis of what the
page is about and that's called the meta
description and then again
the content needs to be readable and
that's important and so in order to be
readable again we're going to talk more
about site speed because site speed's
important okay and when we talk about
responsive design when i say responsive
design that means your site your page
needs a load both on desktop and also on
mobile and so all these things are
important just like an essay competition
google is the judge and they need to be
able to determine what page is best to
rank number one number two number three
etc on google search and then link
building remember i mentioned link
building a moment ago well link building
internally and externally also plays a
vital role and so we're going to talk
about that a little bit later in the
class when we talk about off-page seo
how does google rank website and
basically google follows three basic
steps to rank a website they need to
crawl your website they need to take
what they call back to their servers and
when they take it back to their servers
your web pages they need to
you have them available for indexing so
when somebody actually types in a
keyword into google.com it'll be
available to be found on organic search
so that's what indexing is all about and
then google's job when somebody does
type in a search query is to
basically rank the those pages that
they've indexed from number one to
infinity depending on how many pages are
relevant to that search query so really
it's about crawling indexing and ranking
so crawling is simply a process done by
which google has bots and
what these bots do is they go to your
web server and they're going to crawl
every page that they can find and how do
they find these pages well they
basically follow links you might have
heard the term spydering but that's what
they call search engine spidering so
basically what google's doing is they're
building a web so to speak all the links
that they're following and so when they
can follow all these links on your
website they're going to be able to
crawl them and when they crawl them
basically they're going to take that
content and store it on their servers so
it's available in their index so based
on this method google finds out which
websites have relevant content and which
ones don't based on certain keywords
that are typed into google because if
they can't crawl your website you're not
going to be found and if you can't be
found they're not going to show up for
relevant keywords so we need to make
sure your site's available to be crawled
and we'll talk about that a little bit
later okay but let's show you an example
so let's just go to google search and if
i type in the keyword simply learn okay
i can see i have 1 million 10 000
results okay and that's how many results
are showing up for simply learn okay now
they may not all be simply learned pages
but nonetheless simply learned is ranked
number one here organically and there
are 1 million 10 000 pages related to
the keyword simply learn now when it
comes to organic search we don't want to
get it confused with paid search so
anytime you see paid search you're going
to see
something that says add next to it okay
so we could see that there are paid ads
here but when it comes to organic search
those are generally below paid ads and
so that's where google counts the 1
million 10 000 results and so that's the
whole idea behind crawling and indexing
google is able to cross simply learn's
website and based on all the pages that
they gather they're going to make those
pages available in organic search so if
you type in a keyword and your web page
is not available for indexing then
you're never going to show up for that
keyword so that's why it's important to
make sure your website is available for
crawling and indexing and so when a user
types a query on search google search
the most relevant websites that are in
google's index are going to appear in
the search results so in the example i
gave was simply learn well simply learn
is the brand name of the company simply
learn so there's a lot of relevancy
there so that's why you see simply learn
show up here organically number one like
we mentioned about what is seo and why
seo we talked about that user experience
so there's a lot of factors that go into
ranking relevancy being one of them so
in the simply learn example simply learn
is relevant to a lot of the simply
learned pages because that's who they
are simply learn however simply learn
also needs to make sure that you know
for their pages the page load time is
fast meaning these pages load very fast
for the end user and google also takes
into account other factors like how long
someone is staying on a website or are
they bouncing meaning are they going to
one page that they land on and then
leaving the website okay and so the user
experience is very very important there
are other factors also like language and
location and so for example location if
you do a search say in india the results
are going to be a little bit different
than say the results in the united
states why because google is indexing as
many web pages as they can find so if
somebody's doing a search in india
their results may be a little bit
different than the results show up in
the us because google has different bots
and these bots are crawling different
pages at different times and so google's
index is updating continuously but it's
not real time syncing so if you do a
search in india you may not see exactly
the same thing because both search
engines the google and india and the
google in the us are may not be exactly
synced up so an example would be you
know if you're looking for cafe so if
you search a cafe and say san francisco
you're going to see different results
now if you do a search for cafes in
mumbai you're going to see different
results there's going to be local search
here at the top there may be some paid
search but again you may see different
results because one location but two
google search engines in india and
united states google.com aren't exactly
synced up exactly at the same exact time
you do that search so location is
important language is important and
relevancy is important along with user
experience so all those are important
factors in how google ranks websites
okay so we're going to talk about the
types of seo now so if we want to rank
for a particular keyword on google we're
going to have to apply search engine
optimization and so there's two
strategies to search engine optimization
on-page seo and off-page seo so first
we're going to talk about on-page seo so
on-page seo is nothing more than
optimizing your own website and so when
we say optimizing your own website
there's certain elements on your website
and on your web pages that we need to
take into account and so some of those
elements are headers meta descriptions
title tags linking so all of those
elements are something we can control as
an end user who wants to rank our web
page and our website on google and
before we do anything with our website
the first thing we need to do
is understand what keywords we want to
rank for in order to understand what
keywords we want to rank for we need to
do keyword research and if you do
anything in seo keyword research is the
most important activity that's the most
important thing you can do for seo and
why do i say it's the most important
because you need to understand if you
choose a keyword that you want to rank
for you need to understand how much
traffic you're going to get from that
keyword if you're ranked organically say
number one on google so how much traffic
will you get if you're ranked number one
on google so you need to understand what
the volume is and then number two we
need to understand what the competition
is for that keyword that you want to
rank for so if you choose a keyword and
there's not much competition for it then
chances are you can rank for that
keyword for a web page on your website
quicker than say a keyword that has a
lot of competition so we need to
understand those two basic factors
volume and competition before we choose
a keyword and it's it's simply the
practice of going through the motions of
getting your volume and getting your
competition data so you can choose the
keywords you want and then once you
choose the keywords you want then you
can go and apply on page seo you can
change the title tag the meta
descriptions the headers all those
elements can be changed but first you
need to choose your keywords and so
again the primary components we're
looking for are how much traffic you can
get or the search volume how much
competition there is for that keyword
and of course relevancy okay you need to
be able to choose a keyword that's
relevant to the web page you're trying
to rank for and so let me show you
example how to go through this so the
first thing we want to do is we want to
use a tool and the tool i would
recommend is google keyword planner and
why do i choose google keyword planner
because if we're trying to rank on
google.com or google search engine we
want to be able to get the data right
from the source so google's going to be
able to give us information about how
much volume a keyword has and how much
competition it has so let me show you an
example so if i want to use google's
keyword planner and i want to rank for
the keyword how to become a digital
marketing specialist then i'm going to
type that keyword into google's keyword
planner and what google's going to do is
they're going to give me some trends
about how much volume this particular
keyword gets over the course of a year
and so for that particular keyword i can
see
that there are trends that that appear
for both desktop and mobile so mobile is
important because people start their
search process a lot of times on their
mobile device so we want to be able to
get data from mobile as well as desktop
and so we could see a trend here that
for each particular month over the last
12 months we can see how much volume
this particular keyword how to become a
digital marketing specialist gets per
month and so on average on average over
the past 12 months i could see how to
become a digital marketing specialist is
averages 30 searches a month and this is
on google.com and so google gives us the
volume what they also give us is the
competition and so here i can see google
says for that particular keyword the
competition is medium and so in the
google's keyword planner what they also
do is give me other relevant keywords
that i might think about optimizing for
because you don't want to optimize for
just one keyword so how to become a
digital marketing specialist they're
going to also offer up other types of
keywords that are relevant so just
digital marketing specialist social
media marketing specialist so for those
keywords i can see the volume so for
example digital marketing specialist i
can see the average volume is 1 000 per
month on average of the last 12 months i
can also see the competition is medium
but for some other keywords i can see
the search volume being high like
digital marketing course at 2 900 per
month but also the competition is high
and so what i would recommend is a best
practice is to collect all your relevant
keywords okay and put all your relevant
keywords in a spreadsheet and when you
put all these relevant keywords in a
spreadsheet you want to get the data on
those keywords and the data i'm
referring to is the volume and
competition
so in this case we have volume from
google planner google's keyword planner
and i have competition from google's
keyword planner and so if i go into a
spreadsheet and i put all that
information in here i'm going to be able
to see the volume and competition and so
that's important however one thing to
note here is that google's keyword
planner if we go back just gives us low
medium and high and if i want to compare
numbers to numbers maybe i want to be
able to get exactly the competition
number for the keyword how to become a
digital marketing specialist what i can
do is go into google and i can type in
that keyword so if i type in the keyword
how to become a digital marketing
specialist i can see there's 76 million
results so i could see 76 million
results 76.1 actually and for the
keyword how to become a digital
marketing specialist now that's a whole
lot of results for this particular
keyword especially when the volume is
only 30
per month on average and so what i want
to do is get a more clear picture of the
competition and so what you could
actually do is type in the syntax all in
title and then colon and then your
keyword how to become a digital
marketing specialist and when i do that
i get a different result here i can see
only 136
listings for how to become a digital
marketing specialist but that's not just
136 that's 136
with that particular keyword that we
want to rank for
in the title tag okay so the title tag
is what you see when you type in a
keyword or search query in google search
and the title tag is what you see at the
top of every search result and so now i
can see i typed in how to become a
digital marketing specialist with the
all in title syntax and now i can see
every listing every one of these
136 results have that particular keyword
in it so i could see every one of them
how to become a digital marketing
specialist and why is that important
because now that tells me i only need to
climb over
136 listings to rank for that keyword
how to become a digital marketing
specialist and so the idea here is you
want to get your volume from google's
keyword planner but you want to get your
competition from google search and again
that's simply typing in the syntax
call and title and then your keyword in
this example how to become a digital
marketing specialist once you get those
two numbers you're going to plug them in
to your spreadsheet and then once you do
that for number of different keyword
queries and these keyword queries again
have to be relevant once you do that
then you can go in and pick the keywords
you want to optimize for and that's
important because again if you're not
sure about a keyword then you want to do
the keyword research so you can be sure
of how much traffic you can get and how
much competition there is those are two
important three important factors in
starting the process for on-page seo so
again
you want to create content for
say a keyword like digital marketing
but digital marketing may seem a little
bit broad so you want to probably stay
away from broader keywords because
broader keywords tend to have a lot of
volume which is great but they may also
tend to have a lot of competition but
that's the whole point of doing the
keyword research maybe it doesn't maybe
there's more volume than competition
that's what you need to find out when
you do the keyword research you need to
find those keywords that are relevant to
your content that have a lot of volume
and low competition and then once we
identify those keywords then we are free
to go in and start optimizing our web
pages for those keywords and the first
place we want to start is the title tag
so if you remember my example going back
here to our search how to become a
digital marketing specialist we saw that
every one of these listings had that
keyword in the title tag and the title
tag is important because that's what
users who use google search see first
when they type in a query and get
results so they're going to see the
title tag so the title tag is the most
important element for on-page seo it's
the most important factor because that's
what people see and so ideally when we
choose our keyword we want to make sure
that keyword is in the title tag because
that's what shows up in google search
and that's what makes that particular
web page relevant for that keyword query
so the idea behind a title tag it's
between 50 and 60 characters and so we
want to make sure we stay within that
limit no more than 60 characters because
what happens if it's beyond that then
google will truncate the title tag so if
i go back to my search you can see here
on this particular title tag google
truncated it meaning they added the
ellipses after the title tag because it
exceeded the 60 character limit so you
want to stay within those character
counts and so the title tag is the first
place you should start when optimizing
your website because when we have the
right keyword
in the title tag and somebody types in
that keyword then chances are it's going
to be relevant they're going to see it
and they're going to click through to
your website and that's the whole idea
behind ranking we want to get clicks so
that's how the title tag appears so when
you optimize it you're going to update
the title tag and this is how it shows
up it's going to show up at the top of
your listing okay and it's going to be
bigger and bolder than anything else
google displays so the second thing you
want to optimize is the meta description
and the meta description is simply just
a brief description
up to
155 i would say about 155 to 60 160
characters but probably no more than
that and so the meta description is
nothing more than a summary of the web
page itself so if i go back to my google
search results i see my title tag and i
see the page that this particular
listing belongs to and underneath that
is where i can see my meta description
so in this particular keyword query how
to become a digital marketing specialist
i see the meta description an ultimate
guide on how to build a career in
digital marketing and the skills
required to become a digital marketing
specialist note that it's a well-written
meta description within 155 characters
and it includes the keyword digital
marketing specialist so we're trying to
rank for how to become a digital
marketing specialist and here you can
see become a digital marketing
specialist so there's a lot of relevancy
between not only the title tag and the
keyword but the meta description in the
keyword so when you're optimizing a
keyword you want to start with the title
tag but you also want to update the meta
description because if you don't update
the meta description and you leave the
meta description blank then you're
leaving it to google to add in copy that
they deem relevant and so for on-page
seo we want to take control of the copy
and we want to optimize it for the
keywords we want to be found for so the
meta description is a powerful tool at
our disposal it gives us more characters
to work with it gives us more to talk
about so for that particular page and so
if the title tag is only 60 characters
maximum it's not a lot of information to
try and get somebody to click so the
meta description helps us in identifying
what that page is about in order to get
the click so the two working in tandem
will hopefully increase your
click-through rates so when you're found
organically we want to get the click and
then the third element that's important
is the url and url stands for uniform
resource locator and why is the url so
important because that's what people see
so if i go back to my search result how
to become a digital marketing specialist
notice that the url also includes how to
become a digital marketing specialist
article okay so it's very relevant the
url is very relevant one we can see it
in the search results but two you know
it's relevant to the keyword query and
that's important for the end user and
google google wants to know hey is this
the page that's relevant to the user's
query and if it is then this user is
likely going to have a good x user
experience after they click on the
listing so the url is an element that
helps not only with the click-through
rate but with ranking and having a poor
url structure doesn't help at all
because not only does google not
recognize the url as being relevant but
the end user
may not want to click on that page given
the the way the url looks so you want to
try and avoid a poor url structure so
the rule of thumb is this if you don't
understand what the url is then google
is likely not going to understand what
the url is and so we want to try and
keep our url structures clean and when i
say clean ideally you want to make sure
that whatever keyword you're trying to
optimize that's the keyword that's
included in the url nothing included
that is not understandable so again
going back to our example how to become
a digital marketing specialist it's very
clean the title tag is the keyword the
meta description is cleanly written has
the keyword and then the url is the
other element that the end user can see
and that url includes the keyword in it
so after we've done those three elements
the title tag the meta description and
the url then we want to start optimizing
the page itself so ideally when we say
optimize the page itself the page
remember needs to be structured and when
we say structured it needs to be
structured in terms of you know headers
and subheaders and organized in a manner
in which the end user can read the
article read the content clearly and
concisely without being confused and so
that's the job of headers they add they
add basically an organizational
structure to the content and with
headers there's a hierarchy so you have
anywhere from h1 which is the top of the
hierarchy to an h6 and so you're free to
use any one of those headers when
building out a page in order to organize
the content but ideally you probably
want to stick with an h1 or an h2
because those are at the top of the
hierarchy and what those do is they
actually stress to google that hey
this header with this particular keyword
in it is important so if you use an h6
with the keyword in it it's telling
google hey this is an h6 but it's not as
important so an h1 and an h2 tag show
importance and so let's look at an
example of what that is so here you can
see an h1
is going to be at the top of the
hierarchy so that means it's going to be
bigger and bolder then you have an h2
which is going to be bigger and bolder
than an h3 but not as big and bold as an
h2 so with headers not only are you
organizing the content accordingly but
you're also signaling to google how
important that particular header is and
of course the header needs to include
the keyword we're trying to rank for so
let's take a look again at that example
so if we go to how to become a digital
marketing specialist if i click on that
page i can look at the content and i can
see that there are headers in here so
the headers are there to organize the
content and that's what we want we want
to be able to organize the content and
if you look at the other example i'm
showing here how to become a digital
marketing specialist uh learning paths
explored you can see that's an h1 but
below it's a subheader the growing
digital marketing job market so that's
an h2 and so we're not stressing to
google that that's more important than
h1 but nonetheless we're stressing at
google that it's important nonetheless
so we want to be able to use headers we
want to be able to use keywords in our
headers in order to stress to google
what's important and also to organize
the content because google likes content
organized okay the next element we want
to focus on is internal linking and so
internal linking if you remember
earlier in the presentation it's
basically links from one page on your
website to another and so here we can
see on this particular article how to
become a digital marketing specialist
there's also links to
other pages on
simplylearn's website and so for this
particular content it also links to seo
specialist ppc specialist social media
marketing specialist and digital
marketing specialist so the whole idea
behind internal linking is to link from
one page to another where it's relevant
and in this case it's relevant because
we're talking about how to become a
digital marketing specialist that's what
the whole content is about and so what
simply learns doing here is offering up
other pages on their website that are
relevant to becoming a digital marketing
specialist and so this is a best
practice when you're optimizing a web
page so you want to be able to have
internal linking
on your site and the whole idea behind
internal linking is it also allows users
to navigate through the site naturally
so when i say naturally they don't
always have to refer back to the top
navigation they can naturally and
seamlessly go from one relevant article
or page to another and so that's the
whole idea behind link building and
internal link building it allows google
to identify
you know pages that they want to crawl
and index because they're linked to one
another but it also helps the end user
because it allows the end user to go
from one page to another and it's
signaling to google hey this particular
page is linked to this page so we're
going to also index that page and so
that's the whole important part of
internal linking it's about the end user
experience and it's about allowing
google to find the pages on your website
so they can crawl them and index them so
you can be ranked for them and so also
in addition to
internal linking we want to be able to
use natural language and so what do i
mean by natural language or natural
language processing so what google does
is in terms of natural language
processing they're looking for the
content and the keyword it needs to be
relevant so when your website is about
digital marketing you don't necessarily
want to rank or try to rank for the
keyword digital marketing one it's too
broad two there might be some
competition but three you're probably
not going to write something as broad
like digital marketing so ideally what
you want to do is you want to choose
other relevant related keywords that's
going to be more natural and so that's
what we mean on natural language
processing we want to choose keywords
that are more natural to the content
you're writing so instead of the keyword
digital marketing maybe we want to talk
about the types of digital marketing or
digital marketing examples or what is a
digital marketing strategy or how to
become a digital marketing specialist so
those are all relevant keywords to
digital marketing and more relevant to
the content because if you try to rank
for the keyword digital marketing again
it's probably going to be a little bit
broad probably more competition and not
as relevant to your content and as a
result probably not a good user
experience so think about some other
keywords that you could optimize and
rank for and that goes back to the
keyword research that's why the keyword
research is so important because it
allows us to identify
other key words in the natural language
process what keywords are more relevant
for the content and then another element
to on-page seo is the sitemap and so
with the sitemap it's basically a list
of all the pages on your website and the
whole idea of listing all the pages on
your website in one document is it helps
both users and search engines understand
the structure of your website so they do
two types of sitemaps one is an html
sitemap and that's designed for humans
so if you have a website with a lot of
content at the footer or the bottom of
your web page you probably want to have
a link to sitemap so if somebody clicks
on that site map they're going to be
able to see all the pages on your
website structured in an organized
manner well an xml sitemap and xml is
just a different format it's designed
for crawlers and so the whole idea
remember is google likes to crawl
content when they crawl content they
bring it back to their servers and index
it and so we want to be able to create a
site map for google or other search
engine crawlers and so xml is the format
so let me show you example of how that
looks so if i go to
simplylearn.com and simply type in say
sitemap.xml just as an example i'm going
to get this particular page and this
particular page displays two xml
sitemaps so these site maps are there
for google to go ahead and crawl and
nothing more than a list of all the
pages on your website and so this is a
quick and easy way for google to get a
hold of all those pages so that they can
index them and that's the whole idea
behind seo you want to be able to have
google index all the content you want to
be found for for the keywords you want
to be found for so it all starts with
the sitemap so let's go from on page seo
which in recap is basically optimizing
certain elements on your website so that
you are relevant for a particular
keyword and that meant updating the
title tag the meta description the url
the headers choosing the right keywords
to put into the content having internal
linking and also
updating the sitemap well those are
elements that you can do on your website
so we're gonna switch gears and talk
about a different strategy off-page seo
because without on-page or off page you
can't have a page ranking so the two
work together so you can do as much as
you want on on page but you still need
off page seo and you could do all the
off page seo you want but you still need
on page so both of these strategies have
to be in full effect in order for you to
rank so let's now switch gears to off
page seo and so off-page seo is simply
the process of linking or promoting your
website using link building and so if
you remember i talked about this earlier
on there's two types of links internal
and external linking and so for on-page
seo we used internal linking for
off-page seo we're going to talk about
external linking and external linking
allows us to improve our website's
recognition or relevancy or credibility
and why do we want to improve our
relevancy and credibility and
trustworthiness and authority because we
want google to know that our web page is
trustworthy it is recognized by other
websites and it is relevant for a
particular keyword and so if we can do
that using off page seo methods then
google's going to rank our web page for
the keyword we want to be found for so
it's really off page seo is synonymous
with link building and there's plenty of
opportunities to do link building it
just comes down to creating a strategy
so again some of the benefits to off
page well we talked about you know being
credible and trustworthiness and
relevant we need to do that in order to
rank but there's some other benefits
there so if we have a link on another
credible website then it's likely going
to increase the traffic to our own
website it also creates high domain
authority and so what i mean by high
domain authority is if we have basically
links to other web pages pointing back
to us then basically our domain
authority is going to improve and when
our domain authority improves other
websites are going to want to link to us
so the higher authoritative we are for
our website then other web pages are
going to want to link to us and so the
more external linking we have the higher
the domain authority so it all starts
with linking to
other high domain authority websites so
linking to a high domain authority
website for example having a link on
wikipedia that points back to our web
page creates high domain authority for
us and it helps drive traffic so some of
the other benefits of off-page seo are
credibility so if we're linking from
wikipedia to our web page it does create
credibility for us it also helps us
increase our page rank so remember that
external linking helps build domain
authority helps build credibility
trustworthiness and it's going to in
turn help us rank for that particular
page and then certainly not last having
a good off-page seo link building
strategy increases our brand awareness
because if we're on other high
authority websites wikipedia or say a
social platform it's going to increase
our brand awareness and increasing our
brand awareness increases our
trustworthiness and so if somebody is
looking to say become a digital
marketing specialist then likely instead
of typing in digital marketing
specialist on google they may type in
our brand name in this case simply learn
and so these are all the benefits to off
page seo so it's nothing more than
having links on other websites that are
pointing back to ours and again there's
lots of benefits it's drives helps drive
traffic and increases our authority so
those are things that we want to take
advantage of when we want to rank and
the key behind off-page seo or link
building is always going to be content
so from an on-page seo perspective
having quality content allows that
content to be optimized for relevant
keyword and ranked but also from an
off-page seo strategy
having high quality content allows us to
have other sites and it doesn't
necessarily have to be a website it
could be a social platform or can be
another blogging platform or blogging
website link back to ours why because
the content is original it's natural
it's well structured it reads well and
so that's the whole idea behind off page
you can't have links on other websites
if you don't have quality content so one
of the ideas behind off page seo is not
only do you want to create good content
but you probably want to
spend a lot of time or a bit of time on
others websites so remember the example
i used earlier in this presentation
about having an ice cream blog and ice
cream recipes well it probably wouldn't
be a bad idea to say spend some time on
other blogs related to
desserts related to cakes related to
food in general related to vegetables or
other items that people could link from
so the whole idea is understanding who
else is out there who has relevant
content that you could share so you
could share your content with them they
can share their content with you and
generally that's how it works naturally
anyway in the web sphere if somebody
likes your content they're going to link
to it they don't necessarily have to
wait for you to ask them but it might
not be a bad idea to understand who else
is out there that has content similar to
yours so that you can you know get a
link on that particular website or blog
post and so some other ideas behind
having external links pointing back to
your website is social media so social
media is not just facebook or twitter
but it expands beyond that there's
there's core there's medium there's all
sorts of content generated websites like
reddit so the list goes on and on you
just need to find what's relevant for
your content if it's relevant for your
content then it's worth putting or
trying to get the external link on that
social media platform and then again
going back to my ice cream blog recipes
blog post yeah if you find a particular
blog that you want to have an external
link on there's nothing wrong with
reaching out to that particular blogger
you know in some cases very flattering
but in other cases if the content is
relevant then why not it's only going to
help your end user experience if you add
somebody who has a say a blog about
cakes having their link on your blog
post so there's nothing wrong with it
because it also adds to the user
experience and if you're going to ask
somebody to put an external link on
theirs you might want to be open-minded
and make sure that you're are able and
willing to put an external link on your
blog post or website pointing to their
content that's how the web works
especially if the contents of quality
relevant and of good nature okay so
let's move on and finish up with the
do's and don'ts of seo so we talked a
lot about
why seo what is seo you know how do we
rank for seo what is on page seo what is
off page seo and so
let's just wrap up with some of the
things you again want to do to rank your
page for a particular keyword and some
of the things you don't want to do so
the first thing on the list is optimize
for white hat techniques and what i mean
for
opting in for white hat techniques is
basically everything i just mentioned
today you want to do keyword research
you want to choose a natural language
processing form format so you could
choose keywords that are going to be
relevant natural to the content and you
don't want to opt for black cat
techniques and black hat techniques are
probably not even worth going into
detail but one example is choosing a
keyword arbitrarily like say digital
marketing and just stuffing that keyword
into the content so that's probably not
something you want to do because again
it's not going to be good for the end
user so stay away from black hat and
focus on some of the techniques we
talked about in today's presentation the
other do we want to do is get backlinks
from relevant sites so that's off-page
seo again it's what i mentioned earlier
it's about linking your quality content
to another person's website that also
has quality content we don't want to
have a backlink from an irrelevant site
why because it's not going to be
relevant and it's also going to hurt our
authority because if it's on a site
that's not of good quality then google
is going to look at us and say well this
site is linking to your site but it's
not relevant so therefore you know we're
not going to look at you in the same way
as if you were on a quality website we
do want to use our keywords naturally
because title tags are what people see
first on organic search but you don't
want to use the same title tag on every
page of your website so we want to stay
away from doing that so you want to have
a unique title tag
for every web page on your website and
ideally what does that mean that means
using our keyword research to choose one
or two keywords for page and optimizing
your web page for those one to two
keywords so you ideally what you want to
do is have one or two different keywords
for every page on your website we
definitely definitely definitely want to
write engaging content so the content
should be engaging remember user
experience we want users to stay on our
website we want them to enjoy the
content that they're reading and we want
them to go from one page to another
naturally we definitely don't want to
leverage or plagiarize or just copy
content from others websites because
it's not one probably going to be
relevant to what you're writing about
two it's duplicate content and it's
somebody else's so that's a black cat
technique we want to stay away from i
can't emphasize this enough we need to
do keyword research first before you do
anything else you need to find relevant
keywords and not only that you need to
understand the volume and the
competition for each of those keywords
okay you don't want to choose a keyword
that has low volume high competition you
want to choose a keyword that has high
volume low competition but above all you
want to choose keywords that are
relevant to your content we want to
avoid keyword stuffing so don't take a
keyword and just stuff it everywhere on
the page it's not going to be natural
and google's going to be able to pick up
on that so we want to maintain some
level of quality with our content and
quality with the keywords that we choose
so reminder when you have quality
content it's always going to link
internally to another page on your
website with quality content but it's
got to be natural and don't just build
site-wide backlinks meaning don't just
have an internal link to the home page
or don't have every page on your website
linking to just one page so internal
linking should be natural naturally
linking from one page to another not
only does it help google understand and
crawl all the web pages on your website
but it's good for the end user it's good
user experience and certainly last but
something i didn't talk about does take
time to rank your content so remember
the process you're going to write your
content you're going to choose keywords
you're going to change the elements on
that page for those keywords and all the
while you're going to make sure google
can crawl that content and when they
crawl they're going to index it the
process takes time especially if you
choose a keyword that's competitive so
just be patient if you have quality
content and you've optimized for on-page
seo and off-page seo then you will rank
for that keyword and then make sure your
website's user-friendly and mobile
friendly so we talked about responsive
content earlier so remember most users
today start the process of search on
mobile so we want to make sure your
websites are mobile friendly
well to get this conversation started uh
here's a preview of what matt will be
talking about today keyword research and
search trends
seo friendly copywriting content
optimization website and landing page
optimization content trends analytics
and of course we'll be answering your
questions
throughout so feel free to chime in so
with that
i would just like to
hand the mic over
for a bit here to to met so take it away
mr bailey all right well thank you dan
and as you can tell by the agenda it
seems to be content heavy
and that is certainly uh without an
accident there that
if you've been an seo for any length of
time you can see where things are moving
in the digital marketing industry
or social media content marketing those
types of things
and so
the role of the seo is becoming more
critical than ever in being that
connection
from what are people searching for and
then
what do we publish
seo is that critical link between the
research and the development of content
and that's is only going to increase
more and more over the next few years so
that's why there's a little bit more
emphasis on that content side that
you'll see there
but just you know a little bit more in
detail on that that the role of seo
has primarily been as that
the first line of understanding what the
search engine is doing what do they
require
what are the new technologies coming out
of search and what are the trends coming
from search
how is google changing results what are
they testing
so seos first and foremost are on those
front lines of
seeing what especially google google is
pushing the the envelope more than
anybody and they're testing more things
and so understanding
what is google doing
what are the implications of it uh is
this just a test or are we moving what's
the bigger picture of what they're
attempting to do
and so understanding
that role there of being that early
predictor of what's going on with google
and then being able to translate that
inside your organization or inside your
agency
that is really becoming part of
you know the the representative role of
the search engine optimizer is
understanding here's what's happening
and here's how we're supposed to react
to it
at the very base level it's
understanding those keywords it's
understanding
what are people searching for
and what is their intent
and how do we then apply that into our
content strategy
so that has been really kind of the
foundational
part of what an seo does but it's also
going to
be a little bit larger into looking at
the larger trends of what is google
attempting to do what are the
implications and how do we respond to
that
now of course with part of that keyword
research is understanding the long-term
trends uh over a year two years three
years because if something has a trend
and it's predictable
well then that's something you can bring
into your organization
because i i love to say if it's
predictable it's monetizable you can
make money off it if you know that it's
going to happen every year because you
can prepare for it you can help your
organization prepare for
those increases in traffic especially if
you're able to tie those trends into
specific events
if you can come up with causality what
causes those to happen how do we react
to it how can we develop that and how
can we incorporate that into our
strategy again that is
more of a planning and prospecting
work that a search engine optimizer
would do
and those
skills of doing keyword research and
understanding the long-term view of
keyword research of trends throughout
the year
creating those connections
that is a valuable skill which is only
going to increase
and of course those keywords are
important for
anyone in a marketing field or also
customer service we've seen more and
more
of this
cross-marketing view across an
organization
where marketing is getting more involved
in customer service they're getting more
involved in loyalty they're getting more
involved in
many different
aspects of nurturing customers the
customer experience
and so whenever you're planning any of
these things for social media and what
are we doing with social media are we
educating are we rewarding are we trying
to look for new customers
well all of that requires content that
content is going to have to be
researched as to when do we talk about
certain things and how do we talk about
certain things
keyword research gives you that agenda
it keyword research tells you when
people search for certain content and
also the associated words that they have
and so that applies to your content
marketing your social media marketing it
also applies to when
people become customers and if you do
any amount of uh crm marketing email
marketing or email automation or even
triggered your keyword research can help
in developing the content that will be
in those emails because you'll have done
the research and find out what do people
want
after they make a decision after they
purchase a product what are the needs
that they have what is the information
need that they have and how do we write
towards that so again seo is influencing
the content that is generated by the
entire organization in nearly all
communications
this gets back to seeing the trends that
are happening within the search engine
and you've probably seen this lately i
love this example here so if i want to
make a latte and i type that into google
uh
this is what's interesting the answer to
my question is at the top of the page
now without even going to the website
i can have my answer
for the question
and now there's a couple implications to
this yes it's great we can be at the top
of the rankings we can have our answer
there
but if the answer completely answers the
searcher's question
it doesn't generate a page view they
don't see much of our brand
they aren't in
really they aren't engaging with us at
all they're engaging with google
and so
this gets to the point of how do you
then bring this to the organization as
far as a strategic view of this how do
we approach it how does this change what
we do with our website or with our
content
you can also see here that
people are asking different questions
and this gets to the copywriting of the
website are you generating content that
answers questions because this is where
google is pooling this information as
well as pulling the related questions
that come from that type of content
this also is critical because this then
leads into voice search
and so if you've got a home assistant uh
you use any of the phone assistance or
hey guess what this is coming in cars
uh that you will have a voice assistant
in cars and your search result will be
read back to you
and this is
the beginning stages of that that if you
have a question or a search you would
speak your search and then the first
result would be read back to you and as
you can see it's not coming from the
site it's coming from google
so this is where again we sit down we
look at the strategy what are we trying
to do
what is our strategy as far as
visibility in the search results and
what's going to happen and what's
happening now with this is you could be
answering people's questions and never
knowing it
simply based because google is
delivering the result they're not going
to your site now the possibility of them
going to your site exists
but as more voice searches are being
generated
google is going to deliver a result that
doesn't require a click-through because
it's all happening through audio
so hopefully this uh doesn't uh
all the changes in seo
i would say over the past uh 15 years
have been largely external driven by
google uh as google has taken away
keywords taken away uh keywords and
analytics uh
done numerous things here that have
caused seos to have to react
and again this is one of those changes
uh that causes us to sit and figure out
how are we going to deal with this
change we have some questions already
one of which is google's not spending so
much time focusing on keywords
specifically even though they're still
important where do you suggest that
marketers look for keywords
oh i think the the typical
keyword research tools are still very
viable in fact you'll probably get
better information out of keyword tools
than you will google's keyword tool
google has been combining
keyword concepts under a single
keyword so for example um a great one
that uh we've seen in the keyword
research uh pool table and pool tables
plural and singular
google puts that all under pool table
whereas anyone who you know does any
amount of e-commerce can tell you there
is a world of difference between people
that search for plural and singular
before the the changes in keywords i
could tell you with numerous sites that
we had that if people searched with the
singular version
uh they were about three to five times
more likely to purchase than if they
searched for the plural version
the plural version meant that they were
shopping the singular version
pointed to they were ready to make a
decision
so
google won't show you the data however
between the plural and singular for pool
tables
other keyword research tools however
will show you that
so
even though
you know
even though it's getting more difficult
with the keywords from a marketing
standpoint
absolutely still do your keyword
research write as if you would
uh
you know
you're going to have to do additional
research maybe you know customer
research
you know face to face
asking them to describe how they would
search or what they were looking for or
what problem you solved
because you're going to need a wider
variety of input for keywords
yeah and if you have any way to look
into your competitors i know there are
some tools that lets you let you do that
you can see what
your competitors are at least in their
or their sem you can learn a lot yes
because uh
you can you can tell a lot by what's a
valuable keyword by learning what your
competitors are paying for
and uh also check your ticker analytics
to see how people are actually finding
you uh what's interesting is how is uh
how is right i know right brain is one
of the most influential parts of google
now and i know that that's basically a
lumpy instead of creating separate pages
for
plurals and
other iterations of words rank range is
sort of uh
including all of that and looking for
those words in general content is that
how is rankbrain affecting
search terms and
seo with just keywords
um
you know it's really trying to learn
more of
what exactly do people want
uh from an intentional standpoint
so
trying to put together
uh
unfamiliar searches or unfamiliar
phrasings or i think i read the other
day
um i'm trying to think whose name it was
but it was oh matthew mcconaughey his
name in one week had
like 8 000 misspelled variations
so
somehow
you know
a search engine has to figure out over 8
000 misspellings who did you mean you
know who are you trying to figure out um
you know so it's it's trying to figure
out the intent and deliver the right
result and
you know i think part of this is yes
they don't want seos to be focusing on
individual words
[Music]
and by taking away all that data
you know in a way they have accomplished
that
so
you know what rankbrain is attempting to
do is trying to tie those things
together of
how do we figure out now they're looking
at the minutiae of the difference of
words but they do not want to show it to
us
right so it's not a whole lot you can do
it it's just
you know it's from their standpoint the
best thing you can do is just continue
to write
great content that people want
that answers their questions using a
variety of
using a variety of words that explain
uh you know a great example is you know
if you're writing an article uh you know
baseball season started here in the u.s
if you're writing an article about
baseball you're going to use words like
umpire like balls strikes bats teams
those are all words that build context
and so
they're going to count just as much as
the primary term baseball and in fact
google's going to look for all those
other terms
that that build that context
and so it's it's not so much that single
word anymore it's that variety of
i would call those second tier words
that support the context of what you're
writing about grows are coming more into
play yeah and and of course putting that
in a and a more natural language
type of uh type of phraseology in your
content rather than yes the old days of
keywords you know how many keywords can
we stuff on the first paragraph
what's the optimum number of words in
the in the meta tag
i mean because now it really
if it looks like you're i mean these
google's been penalizing people for
doing stuff like that for years but now
especially with rank brain
the more you can do to look to to write
like a conversation
that people are actually thinking and
asking about i'm sure is a better way
they've always wanted that i mean that
has always been google's goal from the
beginning they have told us to write for
humans
uh
but the problem has been you know there
are a lot of seos there that would
rather take the formulaic approach
and
you know why should i write for humans
i'm just trying to get people to my site
you know i wouldn't they're going to buy
uh and so they you know try to reverse
engineer everything to come up with this
formula of use this keyword this many
times in this part of the page and
you know
whereas google has always said write for
humans first and so by taking away some
of those
other options or taking away the
keywords
it's really guided the industry to do
what they wanted to do and honestly i
think it's
it's a good thing
because the quality of content has to
increase it has to get better
and that is one way that they've
enforced that
exactly what they've imposed their will
on on people who desire to have better
rankings right
the uh i just have one one more question
that people a lot of people are asking
if you have any specific recommendations
for for keyword research tools before we
wow
there are a lot of them um so if you've
got like
raven or
um
trying to think what are some of the
others raven seo tools
um there's one right on the edge of my
tongue uh tracker still word tracker
yeah um
oh
i've got a list of them somewhere here
yeah we can find that out
yeah just look just google out and look
at some of the keyword research tools um
there are a lot of them many of them
offer free trials and so
yeah just get in do the free trial take
a look at what's there um
yeah yeah some come with full service
site management you may not want all
that you may you may want that others
are more standalone independent they
just do keyword research
never choose a keyword research tool
that
doesn't show up at least on page 10 of
the serps
[Laughter]
but yeah and honestly the more you do
keyword research i i've always felt this
way and it's it's the more you do
keyword research
the better equipped you are to do your
job
uh and and by that it's dissecting the
keywords what are people looking for
what are the trends what do they
associate
what are
uh the people places and things so as
you're looking at the keywords you're
not so much looking to see the volume
that someone searched for
you know by uh you know buy a pink car
that's that's a great you know that's
good but they talked about cars they
talked about buying and they talked
about color that's more what we're
looking for is let's start slicing and
dicing this down
what words are they associating what
colors what
uh
features and
by understanding the breadth
of how people search and the questions
they have
it helps you write better content
because now you understand not just
optimizing for one word
people have questions across an entire
breadth of type style color uh place uh
city uh
you know all these types of things and
so that's really what i challenge people
to get out of keyword research is
understanding
the full breadth of what people want
rather than just a single word or a
single phrase this gets into copywriting
you see like i said when you when you
get into
you know are people looking for colors
are they people looking for locations
sizes i want to understand the breadth
of what they're talking about and that
helps me become a better copywriter i
can understand intent if i know the
questions that they have
then we can write answers
and so
you know i want to see how people are
searching you know a great example is is
now we've seen searches increasing for
people searching for you know the best
or the top rated or
uh the reviews i think is yeah
oh yeah for me uh people are actually
typing in what is the best car for me
and i think what they're doing
essentially is is directly asking google
you know based on the two million things
you know about me who would be the best
car for me
um so people are looking for more
personalized information uh so what you
can do is get into the you know the how
to the why
the
you know what it means all these
different
cues that people are giving in their key
phrases
develop your content to answer those
questions
yeah i had actually seen a statistic
that 82 percent of smartphone users use
and this is for businesses
looking for businesses use specifically
the term near me after their search
so even geographically
i don't know if that's anything you can
include in the content but uh well no
you know it's it's blows my mind because
um if they're on their smartphone
they're automatically going to get
results near them
that's kind of interesting so
it's more of a cue for google than it is
for a website because to use that phrase
in any of your
optimization really wouldn't make a lot
of sense
because you don't know who's near you
and if anything especially on a mobile
search google is pretty much going to
ignore that near me because you're going
to get the results near where you are
anyway
yeah um so yeah getting into the search
data people search for what they need
they
they figure out what they're looking for
but now here is where the role of the
seo is going to come in organizationally
is that when you have people writing
content generating content for content
marketing for social media
especially if you're working with
you know like a publisher who is
constantly developing content
now you need to help them
come up with ways to measure success
and also to motivate them to implement
seo tactics in their writing so rather
than
developing catchy headlines
uh that may have a double meaning that
may not play well in search
you need to help copywriters understand
that well your headline while that might
look great on print
in search it's actually going to cause a
problem and so you turn into an educator
for your content developers uh you're
teaching them what works well what's
going to click well what's going to look
well in the search engines versus what
might be confusing
also
uh it's also helping them to understand
you know a great example of this um
before i move on
someone um
gave me a great example is they were
writing an article about holiday time
travel and that was the title of the
article that they put out there and they
couldn't figure out why this article was
consistently getting hundreds or
thousands of visits a month
well after it was published and when we
went back and started looking at some of
the rankings and some of the keywords
and things like that we found out that
the article was ranking really well for
time travel
even though the headline was holiday
so it's helping your writers understand
you know
what makes a good title
but then also
one thing that i worked with one
publisher and one of the things we did
to motivate the writers
was to develop like a a leaderboard of
whose content is generating the most
visits
uh and not only that whose content is
generating the most new visits to the
website uh and then you can carry that
through to
you know for how for different writers
how many visits or views have you
generated in a month or over the past
six months how much has your content
uh performed compared to other content
and you can carry this all the way out
to
you know which writers had the highest
amount of ad clicks uh in their
articles uh which articles uh led to
people to
uh
subscribe again or you know even get
into customer lifetime value uh there's
so many things that you could implement
so from an seo standpoint you understand
already how to look at the success of
game rankings and what it generates in
terms of page views click throughs time
on site uh click depth uh
you know all those types of things that
you can then develop into helping others
in the organization who publish content
start to measure the impact of their
writing
organizationally and then especially if
you're able to tie that to a financial
implication
that shows that this is what it's
contributing towards the business in
terms of revenue
then you become the all-around hero
because you're able to help others tie
revenue to activity
that's great we have someone asking can
this backfire on you for example if
you're starting every headline with
one weird this one weird trick dot dot
um
if you find that you have a lot of
if your bounce rate immediately starts
going up yeah you have because if you're
waiting for time travel or star wars or
something
that everyone's going to be looking for
um then um
uh could that actually negatively affect
uh how google sees you if it's if you
have all these bounce rates they might
see you as uh no longer being relevant
absolutely and it's not just google with
the bounce rate it damages your brand it
damages your credibility i mean it's
it's click bait and
i mean
it doesn't take long for people to
realize click bait is clickbait
um you can just
look at some of the data uh but yeah i
mean
when you see
articles or headlines that are
obvious click bait
people you know you get caught a couple
of times you get fooled a couple of
times it's not always going to work and
so this gets to
you know
how are you positioning your brand
are you positioning your brand as a
trustworthy source of information that
answers people's questions are you
positioning your brand as we give people
what they need what they want
or are you fooling them
to click on an article based on what's
popular right now
uh you know there's a couple questions
that get to how the brand wants to be
perceived in the marketplace uh based on
tactics like that
but great question great question
because
click bait is powerful um but you gotta
ask yourself are we giving people what
they want or are we fooling them into it
and how will that reflect on the brand
right
uh from another keyword standpoint one
thing that i found is very valuable to
do is go out and look and see how people
are searching for the brand and
content associations they make with that
brand uh now this can also get into
other areas you may find that there's
some crossover
where
there's another company with a similar
brand name
and so this will help you understand a
little bit more if you get some of that
crossover traffic but also
from a pr standpoint
do people associate content or ideas
with your brand that you would rather
this will help you become aware of
something that might be out there that
may not be getting picked up
so i i enjoy doing these kinds of
searches because i want to know what
other words associations are people
making with the brand right that you may
need to deal with
yeah and also look at your analytics and
what is linked in your crm to see
how people actually converted because if
you have some long tail keywords in
there that would be good to generate
content on
uh that your best customers are finding
you through that can be super valuable
at least compensate for having some
super clickbaity
words
in there accidentally what's interesting
is that people people are are
a few people are really wanting to hone
in on this uh
backtrack a bit here to
ways to capitalize on certain things
that um
i know people are looking for quick
answers to rank high on google uh but
the question keeps coming up about for
example if there are any ways why
you could restructure your content to
capitalize on things like
near me like should you put in your
opening paragraph you know if you're
looking for a near uh
that's that's almost i
i personally would would shrink from
doing that because i know that that's
something that that seems that a google
i don't want to put words in your mouth
it seems like a google is already doing
that automatically based on if you're
searching mobile but two
if
pretty soon they're going to catch up to
people putting
best and near me and because there's
another question like should i should i
use terms that are
when i when i see the results of
most commonly searched terms
and mobile should i put those in my
in my copy
uh so uh what do you say about that like
are there ways to that you can
legitimately without being uh penalized
capitalism yeah well okay if you're
legitimately publishing an article that
is well researched comparing
different products and you title it best
pet food products or something like that
that's a legitimate
case i have no problem with that do your
homework and create something of value
and
it will do well
if it's good content that people like
now the the near me
is
a bit more sketchy because even though
you may put on your website something
about near you or near me
uh
not everyone who visits your website
remember this is more of a
mobile uh phenomenon these are people on
their phone looking for something near
them a drugstore a car wash uh you know
something like that a restaurant
and that's being computed based on
distance based on
uh you know past preferences things like
that
so it has nothing to do with the content
of your website what i would work on
more is your local business listing in
google and
developing
more reviews for your business
and
working with that uh listing to
add more pictures
like i said reviews uh
they have a function there now where you
can add promotions the more you develop
that google listing that will do a
hundred times more to increase your
visibility when someone is looking for
something near them and they are near
you
then adding words to your website
great would that sound smart
i mean come across a bit forcefully on
some of these things
mainly because i it's it's
it has never bothered me when people out
and out try to
fool google with some really intelligent
things uh i i somewhat tend to admire it
uh but when people try to fool google
with what i would call amateurish things
that are poorly executed
that's where i you know that's where i
get
i get a little ticked off at that
because it's
it create a quality experience that's
what people want
quality experience uh and and that's
really what it gets down to when you
know we with content marketing you're
answering people's questions and so
as people are generating that content
you're also sending them back to the
site you're sending them back to get
answers to register to do things like
that so all those web pages from the
content marketing that they're linking
to
they need to be optimized for your
inbound strategy
and what's interesting is also from a
paid search standpoint the landing page
from paid search you know it needs to be
optimized just like any other page
that's part of the quality score
algorithm does the landing page reflect
the paid search headline does it also
contain the keyword that you're bidding
on so
you've got to look at how people are
developing their landing pages
internally and maybe you can contribute
to that as well in helping improve the
quality score because the optimization
of that landing page is very similar
where i see
employment and industry trends now this
is interesting because talking with the
director of omcp
and some of the surveys he's been doing
of hiring managers hr managers and
technology
uh or in marketing across the
across the the globe here
one of the things that he has seen is
there is becoming more demand
of people who can manage the entire tech
marketing stack
not the single channel specialists
because more and more automation is
handling that
uh more and more you know and this is
where we're going to see the entrance of
ai and machine learning is adjusting
your paid search campaign
with those minute
methods of increasing your click-through
rate uh you know it's going to be
managing those bids so eventually you're
just going to focus more on the content
and eventually ai's going to take over
the content uh so
the demand is for
who were the single channel specialists
of seo paid search social to move into
understanding the entire omnichannel
digital marketing
campaign
and can run and can change and can make
recommendations across the board for the
entire stack of digital marketing
this is where we're seeing more of the
employment trends uh going as well as
the skills demand
is getting away from that single hard
skill to understanding the entire
campaign
and that's going to go into all
different types of things that's going
to include email crm social display
and seos i think are probably
very well positioned in all of these
things
because of the foundation of keywords
the foundation of keywords and
understanding intent and then developing
content that answers those questions
that's needed in email it's needed in
automation it's needed in social and
display you know especially in the crm
automation is someone has to write the
content that needs to be automated and
so again this then gets into
uh looking at the trends uh because
automation you not only need to write
the content but you need to
then plan the content when is it sent
when is this completed when is this done
so understanding the
the sales cycles and how long they go
and when people need certain information
at what times it takes that planning
strategy of being able to do that and i
think seos are well positioned to
understand that full stack of marketing
and the implications as well as the
management of it
and then we get to analytics uh this is
my favorite
um so as an seo or if you're taking on
more of the the omni channel burden here
uh you've got to develop those
measurements that show how effective
not only seo has been but now content
management content management is big
everyone is moving towards it it has
become a significant piece of strategy
however what is lacking in content
is the measurement how do we know that
this content piece that went out whether
it was a video uh whether it was an
infographic whether you know regardless
of what it was number one how do we
track performance number two how do we
know it affected anything
number three what was the pathway where
were we driving people and what did we
want them to do and how successful was
that and then also from an attribution
standpoint
did this lead to other things you know
where did this content piece or where
does this channel help us overall in
attribution in driving new leads or
nurturing people along the path and so
it's getting more than just getting you
know measuring clicks it's it's
measuring actual hard dollars that were
generated based off specific channels or
specific pieces of content uh and then
you know it's developing an
understanding of sales goals what did
the sales department need uh
information to enhance the crm so that
they can nurture people along in the
path uh so it's more than just marketing
it's understanding that full scope that
a company has
yeah that's a it's an excellent point
and i think another thing to keep in
mind too is is use actual conversation
with your sales people
as a one of the few things it's funny
that marketing and sales often are their
own little silos and yeah
i i think one of the best things a
marketer can do is just go and talk to
your best sales people and ask them
what
why are people buying us
what are the what are they what are the
questions they are asking you to answer
um i think that can be a because those
questions
since they're legitimately people that
are that are engaging with your sales
people and making purchases i think
those are the most valuable questions
you can answer in your copy oh
absolutely i mean short of talking to a
customer talking to your sales
department is the best way to get
information um it now my
before i got into seo i was in sales i
took sales training and and
you know dealt directly with people so
it kind of
i had that uh
you know that view of things
but
i i'm amazed at how much people don't
interact with their sales department in
order to learn
uh you know what do people need how do
we answer their questions what you know
what do they respond to but then also
your sales people are the first in line
entering information into the crm and
when leads are created through your
marketing efforts
it'd be good to ask them what additional
information do you need that would make
a better lead
you know
there and there are many times where we
have changed the site
on the recommendation of the sales team
and
you know we we may not have it we didn't
improve conversions but we what we
improved were
the
the the scenario through which the sales
call then came
after the conversion and increased the
close rate just based on changing the
landing page or the thank you page after
the registration
right and it's it's a good conversation
to start having with your sales field
too so that they know what kind of
questions to listen to because a lot of
times they're just not paying attention
you ask a sales person
they made the sale because i was a great
sales guy um
but the more you the more you
work with them as a team and say that
hey you know to get them thinking about
actually listening to what the customers
are asking for and passing that on to
you um you know that of course will will
help lead attribution and
and
all the things you said so yeah
definitely
don't forget the human element in seo
well and this gets to you know this
really gets to it
if the trend now is moving more towards
you know someone who can manage a full
stack it's also moving towards people
who understand how to align sales and
marketing goals
and beyond that it's not just you know
like the example i gave before it's not
just okay we increase the conversion
rate of our registration
okay that's great how did that
contribute to revenue but now it's
understanding that there are things that
we can do
to increase a close rate
that don't always take place on the
website but it's a process
and so now we're analyzing processes
that can be done electronically
and then how do we create a better
revenue stream that way how do we make a
better nurture process now we're getting
into the effectiveness of content and
producing a result
rather than
just you know a conversion uh a sale or
a lead now we're looking at well how do
we make more money based out of this uh
and that's really it's that big picture
of understanding that
you know our job is not just to get
leads it's to create better
profitability which rewards everybody
so it's understanding those touch points
from content uh you know so as content
is being pushed out does it answer the
question does it lead people to the next
stage how quickly does it lead them
there uh can you measure influence from
your content and you know through depth
of visitor to the depth of the page that
they got to
um and then again it's
the experience based on motivations
can you understand that can you
tie together what a customer was feeling
at a specific point through their
nurture stream uh or through this
process as i said if it's getting away
from more just stuff that happens on the
site it's communications throughout the
entire process the entire life cycle of
a customer that's all coming under
the the management really of the
marketing team right now is that entire
customer life cycle communication and
management
and finally this is something a trend
that i've been seeing as well in terms
of
jobs and hiring and also business
function
omcp did a a survey at the beginning of
the year asking people where they spent
the most amount of their time
and specifically an seo and seo managers
and
anyone who dealt with seo
nearly 40 percent of their time was
spent
uh presenting their research
presenting strategy
as well as
uh
as well as explaining their the
reasoning for that strategy
and so seos you need to become a lot
more comfortable in front of people uh
presenting your findings making
recommendations presenting opportunities
trends uh and presenting it in a
persuasive
format
that shows
not a bunch of data charts but shows how
smart you are
in creating new revenue opportunities
for the company
and that is really where we see a lot of
things going are the presentation skills
are becoming part of the demand
for companies
when they're dealing with tech thanks
guys now we have rob to take us through
keyword research google analytics google
tag manager how you can rank number one
on google and youtube how to increase
youtube subscribers how to get traffic
to your website some popular seo tools
and finally some seo tips and tricks
keyword research so
what are we going to talk about when we
talk about keyword research we're going
to talk about why we would do keyword
research for seo we're going to talk
about the types of keywords that we need
to research we're going to talk about
some methodologies best practices on how
to do keyword research some alternate
suggestions we're going to talk about
keyword clustering and then we're going
to talk about some tools that you can
use to do your keyword research so let's
start with the why we would do keyword
research so jessie is planning to
publish a blog of pizza recipes so
she was doing pizza recipes step by step
piece of recipes with sausage homemade
pizza toppings pizza dough recipes thin
crust pizzas she's doing a lot of
different topics on pizza recipes well
what jesse needs to do is understand
what's going to drive traffic to these
blog posts if she's writing about you
know different topics around pizza
recipes so
she's unsure how
these blogs are going to drive traffic
so she really needs to
understand that hey you need to choose
the right keywords to drive traffic so
the question is if you're writing a blog
post about recipes with sausages is
pizza recipes with sausages or recipes
for free the best keywords to use maybe
maybe not so you need to take uh care
and choosing the keywords to align with
your content so that's really the idea
why we would do keyword research because
some of the issues with keywords that
are poorly chosen are they could have
slow search volume for example you may
choose a keyboard that just a lot of
people aren't using to search for or
they can be highly competitive so if you
choose a keyword that's very broad or
popular it can be very competitive and
take you a long time to be found for
that keyword or you could just make the
mistake of choosing a keyword that isn't
aligned with your content or you can
choose keywords but use them incorrectly
with your content so these are some of
the issues that you can encounter if you
just go about choosing keywords randomly
without due diligence without the proper
research so low search volume will lead
to less traffic high competition you may
not even rank at all okay if somebody
finds you for a keyword that's not
relevant to the topic they're just going
to leave the page and if you're not
using the right keywords and or if you
are using the right keywords and not
using them correctly in the content then
your pages may not even be found in
organic search so you really have to
take care in choosing the keywords to me
that's the most important step with seo
is keyword research so we're going to
talk about the types of keyword research
then so we have short tail keywords and
we have long tail keywords so if you
write a blog post about pizza recipes
well what are you going to choose a
short tail or long tail so let's talk
about short tail keywords first so short
tail keywords are keywords that are
usually three key words and a phrase or
shorter in some cases it may be two
keywords in a phrase or shorter so short
term keywords usually have high search
volume which means likely means higher
competition but what it also means it
could be
lower conversions because short tail
keywords like for example pizza recipes
could be considered a short-term key
word but maybe somebody's looking for
homemade pizza recipes or pizza recipes
from their favorite italian restaurant
so
short take keywords may not be as
relevant so if we compare it with long
tail keywords chances are you're going
to have lower competition that's one of
the benefits but you're also going to
have lower search volume but with longer
tail keywords the keyword is probably
going to be more relevant with the
content you're writing about so
therefore the conversion rate's likely
going to be higher so that's really the
difference between short term keywords
and long tail keywords if you want to
look at simplistically short tail
keywords abroad in nature it's going to
capture a lot of eyeballs but those
eyeballs may look at your content is not
relevant versus long tail keywords that
may be very relevant but not as many
eyeballs on them so short tail keywords
the characteristics they're not as
specific usually they're less than three
words they have high search volume and
high competition so if you just choose
pizza recipes it could take you a while
to rank for that keyword but when you
rank you're going to get the traffic but
again it may not convert because the
keyword is broad in nature so pizza
recipes is a short tail keyword that
may not be exactly what you're writing
about in your blog post so it may draw a
lot of traffic but the traffic may not
do anything so the longer tail keywords
are very specific they consist of more
than three words in the search query
they have relatively low search volume
competition so the chance of you ranking
higher faster for that long-term word is
probably going to be greater because not
many other websites are trying to rank
for that same keyword and so the benefit
of that is if you have let's just say
homemade pizza recipes with mushrooms
that's a long tail keyword but if
somebody's looking for that type of
pizza recipe then you know you're going
to track the right traffic and chances
are that traffic is going to engage or
convert based on the type of conversion
you have in place so example would be
homemade pizza dough recipes that'd be
another example more than keywords in
the phrase very specific we're talking
about homemade pizza dough recipes so
we're not talking about just pizza
recipes so it's a little bit more
specific in nature longer tail so these
keywords are used for targeted pages
including blog posts if you're writing a
blog post specifically about pizza
recipes with homemade dough then this is
the keyword you likely would want to use
versus just pizza recipes so let's look
at an example between a
short tail keyword and a long tail
keyword and to accentuate the
differences we're going to use google's
keyword planner tool so google's keyword
planner tool is located in google ads
the google ads platform and when you're
in the google ads platform you can
simply click on tools and then keyword
planner and so what keyword planner
allows us to do is get a sense of the
type of volume that a particular keyword
has so what google's keyword planner
does is they show you the average
monthly searches this is the average
monthly search volume of a keyword over
the past 12 months and so in this
example we're going to choose pizza
recipes and homemade pizza dough recipes
so one short tail and one long tail so
we enter those keywords in we're gonna
click get results and what google's
gonna do is it's going to show us the
volume of those keywords so for pizza
recipe we could see the average monthly
search volume is 33 100 for pizza recipe
so note that pizza recipe and pizza
recipes are closely related keywords and
so what google does is they consider
that a close variance so meaning if
somebody types in pizza recipe then
they're also in google's eyes looking
for pizza recipes so it's a close
variance and so for the keyword pizza
recipe which is short tail we could see
on average over the past 12 months this
keyword received 33
100 queries and so if we hover over the
graph we could see basically the volume
the average volume per month so here i
could see for this particular keyword
here the volume per month is 33 1000 and
then i can see the actual volume over
the past 12 months and then for the long
tail keyword i can see homemade pizza
dough recipe again close variance
homemade pizza dough recipes i can see
over the past 12 months what the search
volume is for this on average is 2400
but i could see here in december the
volume went up to 3 600 but for example
in may it was 1900. so it's going to
fluctuate a bit over the past 12 months
but on average it's about 2400. so
shorter tail a lot more volume longer
tail not as much volume but nonetheless
there is volume here and so these are
the difference between a short tail and
a longer tail and so what google's
keyword planner also does is allow us to
get a sense of what the competition is
and so here i can see the competition is
low for both of these keywords fair
enough so we now know that if we want to
optimize or choose the keyword homemade
pizza dough recipe for our blog post we
know for ranked on page one of google
even in the top spot we can expect about
2 400 search queries for that keyword
now whether you get all 2 400 clicks for
that keyword remains to be seen chances
are you're not going to get all 2400
you're going to get a lion's share of
those clicks but you're going to at
least get some volume on it so even the
longer take keywords have a lot of
promise because there is some search
volume here for this keyword how to do a
proper keyword research so we looked at
google's keyword planner tool in google
ads and we typed in two keywords and we
were able to get a sense of what the
average volume is so we definitely want
to choose keywords based on the
following factors we want to choose it
based on search volume search volume is
a good indicator of the potential
traffic we can obtain so again for the
key word homemade pizza dough recipe we
know that it averages 2 400 a month in
search volume again we may not get all 2
400 but we're gonna get a line share
that we also need to look at competition
and so google's keyword planner gives us
a high medium or low in terms of the
competition but if you're somebody who
wants to get a better sense of what the
competition is and you should because
competition is a key component in
choosing keywords and so what i want to
do is get a sense of how many people are
actually optimizing for that keyword so
google's keyword planner tool is going
to give me a low medium high really what
i want to do is get a better sense of
that numerically so what i can do is go
into google search and i could type in
pizza recipes and i could see
there's about 1 billion results that's a
lot of results however that means that
every potential web page out there on
the internet that mentions pizza recipes
is going to be included in this number
here and so i want to get a better sense
of who's optimizing for pizza recipes so
i'm going to put in the all entitle
syntax and so what that is going to ask
google to do is tell me all the websites
that have pizza recipes the keyword
pizza recipes in the title tag so if i
do all entitle colon space then pizza
recipes my result drops down to 336
thousand so what that tells me is that
there are 336
000 results with the keyword pizza
recipes in the title tag now if i want
to focus in on my other keyword if i
choose uh my other keyword was a longer
tail keyword homemade pizza dough recipe
so if i type that keyword in the
homemade pizza dough recipe or recipes
remember close variance and i just click
enter or type the keyword in and hit my
enter key i'm going to get 35 million
results but again is that really an
indicator of the type of competition i
have no because every listing that
matches homemade pizza dough recipes is
going to be included in the search
results so i'm going to type in my all
in title colon space and then i'm going
to get a better sense of how many
websites have the keyword homemade pizza
dough recipes in the title tag and i get
2160 different results so here i can see
the first result in the title tag
homemade pizza dough recipe second one
homemade pizza dough recipe so these are
sites and web pages that have that
keyword in the title tag so now i have a
numerical number to work with and so the
thing you have to understand about seo
specifically about keyword research is
you need to do research on a few
different keywords not just one or two
so what we want to do is have a
spreadsheet the spreadsheet is going to
contain keywords that we can potentially
want to optimize for choose as keywords
to optimize for seo and so my
recommendation is you come up with a
theme first so the theme for us in this
exercise is pizza recipes and so that's
our theme so we chose the keyword pizza
recipes so the close variance here is
pizza recipe what was the volume well we
know the volume was 33 100 for pizza
recipe so what are we gonna do we're
gonna put that number in in our volume
column what was the competition well if
we go back and type in pizza recipes it
was 683 000 so i'm gonna type in 683
000. what was our next keyword well it
was pizza or homemade pizza dough
recipes
so if i go back for this particular
keyword is 2400 so i'm gonna put 2400 in
under my volume column and then what was
my competition well my competition was i
typed that keyword back in
2160. so i'm going to put
160. so now i have an idea of what kind
of volume and what kind of competition i
have now you want to do this for a
number of different keywords and when
you do it for number of keywords what
you do want to do is obviously choose a
relevant keyword that has high volume
and low competition so another way of
saying it is the volume or ratio of
volume to competition and so basically
what we could do is take volume divided
by competition if i make that a
percentage i can see it's 0.35
is the ratio between volume and
competition if i do the same for my
longer tail keyword 2400 divided by 2160
i can see that 111
so this just kind of proves the point
that yeah i'm still going to get some
volume but i have a better chance of
ranking for this longer teal keyword
homemade pizza dough recipes so you want
to be able to do that for a number of
keywords and examine the volume the
competition and the ratio between volume
and competition for your themed keywords
in this case pizza recipes so relevancy
you want to choose keywords that are
very relevant to the content that you're
writing and then again commercial intent
what keywords are going to drive more
conversions and revenue for the business
so when we talk about commercial intent
we're talking about you know are you
choosing keywords that are going to get
somebody to do what you want them to do
so we could say you know download pizza
dough recipes so if somebody's typing in
the keyword download pizza dough recipes
then chances are they're going to find
you come to your side and take action by
downloading that pizza dough recipe so
you want to be able to also think about
the intent of the keyword is it going to
help you drive conversions and revenue
if you're an e-commerce site so search
volume is the average monthly search
volume made for a particular keyword and
phrase so we can get that number using
google's keyword planner tool in the
google ads platform we want to target
keywords with high search volume that
will help bring traffic to the website
we want volume but we want to take into
account seasonality as well so that's
where the google's keyword planner tool
comes in place because if we go back
again we can just hover over we can get
a sense of any particular trend going on
or seasonality so for example if i saw
large growth in the winter months and
not much volume growth in the summer
months then that might indicate to me
that this keyword is more popular during
the winter time so pay attention to the
graphs that you know the keyword planner
tool gives you use them to your
advantage to take into account
seasonality so a good example would be
funny halloween costumes well we know
that for halloween you're going to have
a spike probably towards the end of
september all the way through october
and then it's going to drop after
october 31st which is halloween so
that's an example but in the case of
pizza recipes you know you may find that
more people are choosing to search for
pizza recipes during maybe the summer
months versus the winter months so pay
attention to seasonality it will affect
search volume so competition based on
our example it's one of the most
important key metrics you don't want to
choose a keyword that's highly
competitive because if it's competitive
then it's going to be harder to rank
number one or even on page one of google
depending on competitive it is so high
search volume low competition in other
words the ratio between the two is the
ideal combination so going back to the
spreadsheet recommend you have that
spreadsheet handy put your theme in
place okay theme pizza recipes we use
google's keyword planner tool to find
the volume we use the all in title
syntax to find the competition so we
entered both of those numbers in and we
get our ratio and so when you have these
numbers for a number of different
keywords you want to be able to choose
that ratio of high volume low
competition but always relevancy always
trumps ratio so always go with a keyword
that is going to be relevant to your
content don't choose a keyword that's
not relevant if you choose a keyword
that's not relevant it's not going to
bode well for user engagement so the
difficulty of a keyword ranges from 0 to
100 in google's keyword tool so it's
going to be easy it's going to be medium
it's going to be hard but my
recommendation is also to get the
numerical factor and that's the all in
title syntax and again relevancy is what
drives the traffic to your website and
keep the traffic there on your website
and also not only will keep the traffic
on your website but hopefully get that
traffic to engage and convert so that's
the key about relevancy you always want
to choose keywords that are relevant to
your content even if it's sacrificing
volume relevancy again trumps volume and
competition so always choose relevant
keywords first so when you do that
you're always almost guaranteeing that
at some point somebody's gonna find your
content because somebody out there might
be looking for it and if they do you're
gonna get found and then the
engagement's gonna be better so
understand your business find keywords
that are relevant to your business and
then focus on those keywords that'll
help you with getting the right traffic
to your site always keep in mind the
commercial intent so these keywords are
more specific and result in conversion
rate for example buying is a good
commercial intent keyword so if you
really want somebody to come to your
website and buy then focus on those
types of keywords in the case of the
pizza recipes maybe its download could
be our commercial intent keyword again
there may be low search volume but those
are the type of keywords you want to
focus on because that's the type of
traffic you want to drive to your site
so some other examples are commercial
intent keywords or discount deal your
coupon shipping you don't don't be
afraid to use some of these keywords as
part of your longer tail keyword phrase
again the volume may not be high but the
traffic quality is probably going to be
better so keyword research is the
foundation for seo so if you have chosen
your keywords properly then if you do
get ranked for those keywords then it's
going to lead to better engagement with
some conversions and so when we talk
about keywords we also want to talk
about our primary and secondary keyword
so every page should have at least a
primary keyword and then a second carry
keyword to work with so primary keywords
are really defining the nature of your
content the secondary keywords are
relevant to the primary keyword so why
do we choose a primary and secondary
keyword because you may choose a keyword
as a primary keyword that is relevant to
the content but may not necessarily rank
very high or have a lot of volume that
secondary keyword is also relevant to
the primary keyword but also relevant to
content and you may rank for that
secondary keyword so you always want to
go with two keywords versus just one
keyword want to give your yourself a
chance to rank for at least two
different types of keywords of relevant
nature so for web page there can be
several secondary keywords but only one
primary keyword so your primary keyword
is always going to be relevant to your
content secondary keywords can be
relevant to the keyword but and you may
have multiple secondary keywords but
it's also going to be related to the
content and it gives you a better
opportunity to be found between both the
primary and secondary and search okay so
let's take a look at another example of
how to use primary keywords and
secondary keywords when choosing
keywords so if a primary keyword is
healthy diet plan remember healthy diet
plan is directly related to the content
so that's what we're talking about but
these secondary keywords are also
related to content and play off the
primary keyword and so what we want to
do is go to cool google's keyword
planner tool and get an idea of the
volume for healthy diet plan and then
also the volume and competition for some
of these secondary keywords like healthy
diet for weight loss healthy diet food
low carb diet healthy meal plans and
diet plan weight loss so if i go in to
google's keyword planner and type those
keywords in i'm going to choose get
results and now here i could see healthy
diet plan keyword i'm focusing on as my
primary keyword has an average monthly
search volume of 9900
and then some of my secondary keywords
healthy diet foods diet plan weight loss
low carb diet you know google will give
me a number of different keywords to
work with so i'm going to look at the
search volume of those as well and so
ideally what i want to do is be able to
then look at the volume and then look at
the competition so healthy diet plan i
go into my keyword analysis here that's
my theme so that's my keyword what's my
volume for healthy diet plan 9900
what's my competition so my competition
is 74
700 and that's going to give me a ratio
of volume to competition of 13 so that's
what my contents about that's a
considered a short-tail keyword because
it has a lot of competition and so my
ratio is 13
and what i want to do is i want to be
able to put these other secondary
keywords in here as well maybe even go a
little longer tail because i want to be
able to
find two key or at least two keywords i
want to be able to find my primary
keyword that's relevant to my content
and then i want to be able to find my
secondary keyword which is again related
to the primary keyword which is also
related to the content and so i want to
be able to choose two keywords basically
and i want to choose two keywords that
are relevant that have good ratio
between volume and competition so that's
the whole idea again on how to do
keyword research you want to be able to
find your keywords use the tools
available to you and get a sense of what
the volume is what the competition is
look at the ratio between the volume and
competition and then based on the
content choose that primary keyword and
then again based on the keyword you
chose choose some secondary keywords as
well because you want to be found for
not just one keyword but multiple
keywords okay let's look at some
alternative suggestions to keyword
research so for doing keyword research
we want to take into account lsi
keywords we could take into account
other platforms that host a lot of
content like quora or reddit we can use
google suggestions in the keyword search
bar we can use popular platforms like
wikipedia and we can use social media
bookmarking like reddit so there are
lots of suggestions that we can obtain
from various sources so let's start with
lsi keywords and lsi stands for latent
semantic insect indexing and so
basically what it is it's just keywords
that are linked to your primary keyword
and so when you're choosing keywords you
always want to choose that primary
keyword and then secondary keywords that
are similar to the primary keyword and
usually those are lsi or latent semantic
indexing type keywords so they're used
to drive relevant traffic to your page
so if you're focusing on one keyword we
want to have other keywords that are
similar to increase our visibility on
the search engine result pages so we
could find latent semantic indexing
right in search so if we use the term
healthy diet if we go to google search
for example if i type in healthy diet in
google search all i need to do is scroll
to the bottom of the page and i can see
searches related to healthy diet so
healthy diet menu healthy diet essay
what does a healthy diet look like
notice at the top google's also giving
me some other suggestions here so
they're saying low-fat diet veganism
gluten-free diet so there's lots of
different suggestions right in google
search bar so all of these are lsi
related keywords so if you're optimizing
a page for a healthy diet then you could
choose low-fat diet as a secondary
keyword you can use gluten-free diet as
a secondary keyword it really depends on
what the content is but you always want
to support your content with as much lsi
keywords as possible so you can be found
for as many different keywords as
possible in google search so it's
important because if you have a blog
that you know talks about python so how
do the search engines know if the
website python is about the programming
language or the snake so
google for example uses lsi keywords to
understand what the page is specifically
focusing on so if you're just focusing
on python and your content you want to
support that with lsi keywords and so
that will allow your web page to better
communicate with google also to have the
visibility to show up on search so they
can certainly improve your search
positioning and featured snippets as
well so if you have a keyword that
answers a question you could certainly
be found for feature snippet for example
maybe you know healthy diet recipes if i
type that in you can see here there's a
featured snippet so if i'm talking about
recipes that's a key word i may want to
use and if i use that then google has an
opportunity to see what my contents
about and place my information at the
top in this featured snippet you can
also again see what some of the
questions are being asked what males are
good for weight loss what is a good
healthy diet plan all of these can be
keyword phrases that you can use so the
answers are right here in google so core
is a great platform because core is a
platform that people go and ask
questions and a community responds with
answers or responses to that particular
question or topic and so the great thing
about core is it's a good i it's a good
place for you to go to get some ideas
about a specific topic so if we're
talking about healthy dieting so we can
find keywords with high search volume
right in core so the whole idea is you
can look at you know the top five
questions for specific topic like
healthy dieting and find relevant
keywords to healthy dieting so if you
just type in that particular keyword in
quora you're gonna probably get some
responses to questions or responses
to somebody else's question and so if we
take a look at core for example so if i
just type in healthy dieting what i'm
going to do is i'm going to get some
responses to
the topic healthy dieting so what's the
best diet for healthy living what are
the top five tips for a healthy diet
habit so all of these could be keyword
phrases that you could take away with
for your own content and so the benefit
here is you're getting kind of an idea
of what's trending what people are
talking about and if you use tips for a
healthy diet habit for example and you
optimize for that well again that could
turn around and bode well for you
because you could be featured in google
as a featured snippet at the top here
you can also turn around and use lsi
related keywords for healthy diet habits
and you can simply just look for those
lsi keywords right in google remember at
the bottom or at the top if i scroll
down i could see some related lsi
keywords at the bottom so right in
google as well you can see in the google
search bar that google provides some lsi
related keywords to your query so if i
go back here and type in healthy diet
recipes i can see here google suggesting
some other related keywords healthy diet
menu healthy diet for men healthy diet
foods healthy diet for women so these
are all lsi related keywords that you
can use to support your primary keyword
and the content you're writing about so
we've talked about lsi keywords where to
find them so they're found right here
they can be found at the top of google
and they can be found at the bottom you
can also then go to core as well and get
some ideas for the types of questions
that are being asked so if you ask a
question and use that as your keyword
phrase then again you have an
opportunity of showing up for a featured
snippet in google just by doing some
additional research within google itself
or on quora so according to google the
autocomplete predictions are
automatically generated by google's
algorithm without any human intervention
it's based on a number of factors but
the primary factor is how often past
users have searched for terms so google
collects all the keyword queries that
somebody types in and they're suggesting
some of the most popular terms that
people have typed in so if i go back to
google again if i start to type in
recipes i could see some of the other
queries that somebody else has typed in
or some of the most popular queries
related to that topic so if you enter
the keyword healthy diet google's going
to suggest multiple keyword suggestions
that users have asked in the past and
you could certainly get the search
volume of those keywords just by looking
in google itself i could see for healthy
diet recipes billions of pages related
to healthy diet recipes i can also get
the search volume by going into google's
keyword planner so if i type in healthy
diet i'm going to be able to see what my
search volume is for that keyword and in
addition i can see the seasonality of
that particular keyword and in addition
to that google is going to provide some
other related keywords to my search
query so if i'm looking for healthy diet
google's going to suggest hey maybe you
should choose healthy food or healthy
eating or how to lose weight so those
are lsi related keywords that google
provides in the keyword plan which is
built into the google ads platform
another option for you is wikipedia so
wikipedia is a vast platform of content
so we could turn wikipedia into our own
asset and use it to our own advantage by
finding relevant keywords in an easy
fashion so with wikipedia we can
identify a list of keywords in the meta
description itself we could choose
keywords from the first paragraph of
wikipedia that has many relevant
keywords or we could take a look at
keywords from the wikipedia content
section so we can also see additional
pages like the see also section that
gives relevant keywords that you're
looking for we can also look at the
references section as they contain
relevant keywords so we go to wikipedia
as an example and i type in healthy diet
into wikipedia here i can get just in
the first paragraph alone i can see
some additional keywords that i might
choose to use like micronutrients i
never knew that micronutrients was
related to healthy diet but wikipedia is
providing some information about what
micronutrients is and maybe i can use
that as a keyword an lsi related keyword
to my content so if i scroll down i get
to see also section so it might give me
some information food information
consumers for example dietary guidelines
i can look at categories like dietetics
and diets i can also look at the
references section so i can also see
what information was provided like
health effects of overweight and obesity
i can look at diet and physical activity
so all of these are related to
my main keyword healthy diet so the
answers are right in here on the
platform they're just all over the page
so wikipedia has an abundance of
information you just need to know where
to look so again with wikipedia you can
look no further than the first paragraph
you look no further than the see also
section the references section category
section there's lots of information
right on the page itself to help you get
ideas for keywords so if you google your
keyword with wikipedia term in the
search query and get relevant keywords
from the title tags on the serp so you
can also do that as well so if i type in
healthy diet wikipedia in search i can
also get some information here as well
so people also search for healthy food
advantages or healthy food habits essay
or information about healthy food all of
these are related to
my keyword healthy diet so again another
bit of information for you to choose or
look to choose some additional keywords
for so reddit it's a popular community
where
people post content and discuss a
variety of topics so that's what reddit
is so with the help of subreddits an
individual can find relevant keywords
with with high search volume so in
reddit there's an easy way to find out
keywords they have a keyword tool called
keyword it so keywording is the average
monthly searches for a particular
keyword so if we type a word and key
read it and choose keywords from the
auto-generated list this tool will
extract the keywords and give us those
relevant terms with search volumes so if
we go to the keyword it and show an
example of that for example healthy food
if i get keywords i can see what
keywords are relevant and the search
volume of that keyword so if i just type
in healthy food keyword tool is going to
tell me some relevant keywords and what
the volume is so if you don't have the
keyword planner tool and google ads
available to you this is a good
alternative solution to finding keywords
so it's free you just need to go to
keyword dot com type in your keyword
click get keywords and what it's going
to do is give you some relevant keywords
related to your primary keyword with the
search volume let's talk about keyword
clustering now so the whole idea about
keyword clustering is to
really take advantage of the keywords
that we're optimizing for to gain higher
ranking so if we can cluster keywords
together in a theme and
that theme of keywords is relevant to a
specific page of a website then we have
a better opportunity to rank so in other
words why do we have to target just one
keyword when we can target many so keep
in mind you know lsi keywords we want to
group a bunch of keywords together that
are similar for content so for example
after some keyword research you can
thematically group keywords into a core
topic so for example we can cluster
these group of keywords together like
for example what is seo how does seo
work intro to seo what are the basics of
seo all of those are related to the core
theme what is seo another cluster of
keywords for example could be seo
techniques seo best practices tips and
tricks website optimization on-page seo
techniques etc so those are clusters of
keywords okay that we can group together
in themes and if we group keywords
together in themes we can apply that to
a particular content on our website so
the whole idea behind clustering
keywords it's going to provide more
diversity more of an opportunity for us
to be found so that's the whole idea
behind clustering so some additional
steps remember stay up to date on
industry news to brainstorm your ideas
first and identify a list of keywords
i.e a theme of keywords that you can
cluster together and then you could
determine the keywords that your
competitors are already ranking for so
for example if we want to rank for the
keyword seo best practices for example
we can use a tool called keyword moz if
i go to keyword the keyword explorer
tool in moz and just type in seo best
practices
what it's going to do is it's going to
give me some volume related to that
particular keyword but more importantly
what it's also going to do is it going
to show me what pages are already ranked
for that particular keyword so therefore
i can get a sense of who is already
ranking for that keyword so here i can
see mozmoz medium.com alexa.com so i can
get a sense of what web pages are ranked
for particular keyword or group of
keywords i want to rank for myself so if
we look at tools for keyword research
look no further than moz that's the mods
of the tool i would just use but you
could also use google's keyword planner
which we used in the example so for
example if i go back to the google ads
keyword planner if you're in google ads
you click on tools you click on
cleveland planner and what keyword
planner does is it provides you for a
particular keyword the average monthly
search volume over the past 12 months it
provides you information on seasonality
so if i hover my mouse over a graph i'm
going to be able to see the volume per
month over the last 12 months what the
keyword planner also does is it provides
me some additional ideas for my
particular keyword and in addition to
that it's going to provide me some sense
of how competitive that keyword is by
telling me whether it's low medium or
high in terms of competition so there's
sem rush there's also other additional
keywords tools out there like word
stream or href or the reddit tool
keyword it and then moz is is another
tool i particularly use so if i go to
moz again here i can just type in a
keyword that i'm interested in it's
going to give me the search volume of
that keyword it's going to give me the
level of difficulty so 50 out of 100 so
it's halfway between difficulty and easy
and then it's going to give me some
additional metrics like for example what
my expected organic click-through rate
would be if i were to rank for this
keyword but more importantly what i like
about this is we could see exactly what
other sites are linked to this
particular keyword we're interested in
so here i can look at the top 10 list so
this is moz's keyword explore tool so
that's what this tool is and it's part
of moz.com so there's a lot of tools at
your disposal i particularly use moz i
particularly use google's keyword
planner and those are the tools i use
but there are lots of tools out there
google analytics i'm very excited to be
with you today because google analytics
is one of my favorite google platforms
and my favorite topics so let's talk
about what we're going to cover today
and we're going to start out with how to
set up a google analytics account and so
we're going to talk about everything
that entails including creating your
google analytics account we're going to
talk about setting up a property in your
account and what a property is we're
going to talk about setting up a
reporting view in your property and
we're going to talk about installing the
tracking code so those are the series of
steps we're going to go through today in
terms of setting up a google analytics
account so let's get right to it and so
really the prerequisite here when it
comes to setting up a google analytics
account is to have a google login and id
so when you actually go to google
analytics you need to be able to sign up
or sign in and so once you actually sign
in then you're gonna go walk through a
series of steps but really that's really
all you need to get the account going is
a google id and login so if you have a
gmail account or an other email account
that you use for other google products
then you're good to go that's all you
need to do so when you actually go to
sign up for google analytics you're
going to be asked to set up a new
account and these are the series of
steps you're going to walk through or go
through to set up a new google analytics
account so you're going to choose an
account name and then you're going to
choose a property name okay so the
account name can be anything you want it
to be the name your company your name
whatever you want to name it the
property name is really the website name
so what website are we talking about so
here i'm going to set up a fictitious
website name for now it's called demo
simply learn so the url for this website
demo simply learn is going to be
demo.simplylearn.com so that's the
property when we talk about properties
and analytics we're really talking about
what websites we want to measure and
then you're going to be asked to choose
an industry category and so for simply
learn we're in jobs and education but
you have a number of different
industries that you could choose from
this is important go ahead and choose
the
most relevant industry that your
particular business is associated with
okay and i'm gonna talk about why that's
important here in a minute and then
you're gonna choose your time zone and
the time zone is also important because
that's when the day starts in analytics
then the day ends based on that time
zone so the data that google analytics
collects starts and ends with that time
zone so very important to choose the
time zone your business is located in
okay and then you have some additional
options here okay so you have some
settings and so the first setting is to
allow google products and services so if
you opt into this then basically what
google is going to do is share some
products and services with you via email
i would go ahead and opt into that
that's of course recommended by google
it doesn't hurt to hear from google on
related products and services that may
enhance your business the second is
benchmarking so benchmarking to me is
something you should opt into so going
back to that industry and category we
chose jobs in education so by opting
into benchmarking basically what google
is going to do is share
your data that it collects on your
website in this case
demo.simplylearn.com
it's going to share that data
anonymously
with others in the industry in this case
jobs and education
and because you've opted in it's going
to do the same exact thing for you it's
going to share anonymous data on other
websites in the same industry and the
benefit of that is we get to see
what other websites or how other
websites are performing compared to ours
what's the benchmark in our industry and
so the benchmarking to me is important
and i'm gonna go over that in a few
minutes when we go over the different
reports but to me i would always opt
into benchmarking because this is the
only report google provides in analytics
about how others in your industry is
performing versus your website okay so
it's a way to compare your website
performance against others in the same
industry the other options here
technical support and account specialist
i would also recommend you opt into
those because then it allows you to
basically
google allow google access to your
account and they'll be able to help you
if you occur or run into any issues so
these are the options in setting up a
google analytics account it's very
simple very easy to do you're just
entering in a few fields note that we
talking about a website right now so i'm
talking about demo.simplylearn.com
but just know that if you want to track
a mobile app google analytics will allow
you to do that as well you just choose
the option mobile app so we're tracking
a website we want to know how users
behave when they get to my website and
that's what google analytics is going to
allow us to measure and look at we just
need to do a couple more steps in the
process so once we fill out these fields
here we're going to click get tracking
id now i'm going to accept the terms of
service i'm going to accept another
terms and service in relation to data
protection i'm gonna click accept once i
accept i'm gonna be able to get some
tracking code the tracking id is the id
associated with your account and so
this number is going to be associated
with your account so your account id
starts with ua and it's gonna be this
number here now the dash one is the
property you set up so in this case i
set up demo
demo.simplylearn.com if i wanted to
track multiple websites under that same
account then i can certainly set up
multiple properties just know that every
property i set up in that account is
going to have a dash 1-2-3-4
etc depending on how many properties i
set up so by default i set up one
property so my first property id is dash
one if i set up a second property the
same account number it's just gonna have
a dash two and that's important because
that id that account and property id is
going to be associated with that
particular property or website so again
once you finish setting up the account
settings then you're going to be asked
to add some tracking code to your site
and that tracking code is going to be
related to the account and the property
so notice my tracking id up here
notice the tracking id and the snippet
of code now this snippet of code needs
to go on every page of your website that
you want to track and you don't have to
put it on every page but if you want to
track website behavior on every page
your website then it needs to go on
every page of your website so if you're
using a you know platform like drupal or
joomla or even more popular platform
like wordpress adding the tracking code
site-wide is as easy as maybe adding a
google analytics plug-in to wordpress
for example and then just simply
plugging in the id now there's an
alternative to adding the google
analytics tracking code to your site and
that's google tag manager so google tag
manager is the way i would recommend
going so if you're not familiar with
google tag manager i would recommend
watching the
youtube video we have on google tag
manager you can just go to youtube type
in simply learn google tag manager and
this will give you a nice overview of
you know what google tag manager is and
how it works but basically this is the
way i would go and i would recommend
that in addition having google analytics
you set up a google tag manager account
and then that way you can put the
tracking code in google tag manager so
if i go to google tag manager and i just
go into an account on tag manager i can
just simply put in the google analytics
id right into tag manager and so if i
have it in tag manager then tag manager
is going to be the place that holds the
code and fires page view when somebody
comes to my website so that way i don't
have to add the tracking code to my
website if i do it in tag manager so
that's the recommended method for me is
to add the google analytics id
associated with tag manager if you can
associate it with tag manager then
that's the easier route to go versus
putting code on your website okay so
again take a look at the video we have
on youtube for google tag manager that's
the route i would go now once you do get
the tracking code on your website
whether that be through google tag
manager or through a plugin or you know
just simply adding the script to your
site to pages on your site then what's
going to happen is you're going to start
collecting data so that's ideally the
way it works you need to add this code
to your website now if you're not ready
to do that and you simply want to
basically understand how google
analytics works then i would recommend
getting access to google analytics demo
account and so if you just type in and
search google analytics demo account
basically what you're going to do you're
going to choose the first listing there
and you're going to go to demo account
so if you have a google analytics or
google login then all you need to do is
click on access demo account and so what
google's going to do is put this demo
account into your account and so it's
going to look something like this so if
i click on demo account here it's going
to add to my google analytics account so
i'm going to have then access to the
demo account from google and google
analytics so i would recommend going
this route here if you're not familiar
or you're not sure what you're getting
yourself into so think of the demo
account as kind of a test drive you're
test driving google analytics before you
even add any code to your website so
again all you need is a google account
and if you have a google account
and you add the demo account to your
google analytics account you're going to
be able to see how analytics works okay
and so that's what i would also
recommend so if you're not ready to
start adding code to your website then
what you can do is just simply add the
demo account and then once you add the
demo account you're free to peruse
around google analytics to see the
different types reports it has to offer
now when you do actually set up a google
analytics account you're going to have
some settings that you're going to want
to pay attention to so when you set up
the account you have the account name
and then you have a property so under
each property you have by default you're
going to have one view and so here you
can see this view here so if we look at
the account we set up we set up a demo
simply learn account property is demo
simply learned so that's associated with
the website we're going to track and
then again by default under each
property you're going to have a view and
so by default the name of the view is
going to be called all website data and
so in that view is where all your
analytics data is going to be stored so
you can see my screen here there's a lot
of different settings you have you have
settings under the account you have
settings under the property and you have
settings under the view so we're going
gonna talk more about these settings in
future webinars for advanced google
analytics users but for now know that
there's a bunch of settings that you
have that you can play around with when
it comes to google analytics anything
from adding users to your google
analytics account your google analytics
property review you can actually set up
goals you can set up filters you can set
up segments you can link up google ads
you can
you know set up remarketing list there's
a lot you can do in terms of the
settings as it relates to google
analytics but so no those settings are
there they're located right down here
and this little sprocket icon that's the
admin icon so if you need to get to
these settings at any time you can
simply just click on the sprocket or the
admin icon and then you'll be prompted
to choose any one of these settings here
that you want to edit or alter so now
let's take a look at some google
analytics reports so once you've
actually set up your account you have a
number of different reports that you
have available to you in google
analytics so we're going to take a look
at you know customize reports we're
going to look at real time audience
reports acquisition behavior and
conversion so these are all the
different reporting buckets if you will
that you have available to you in google
analytics so if i'm an admin and i'm
looking at the google demo account let's
start out by looking at real time so if
i click on the real time report and i
just click on overview so basically what
this is going to do is show me at this
point in time how many users i actually
have active on the website okay so
that's why they call it real time
reporting because it allows you to see
the behavior of users who are currently
on your website and so this is the
overview report under real time and you
can see here i can see that 79 percent
of my users are coming from desktop 18
20 are coming from mobile and then
approximately three percent coming from
tablet here i can see how they actually
came to the website so this is the
referring source if they came from
say search or social i can see the
source there and i can see what pages
they're active on and then here i can
see what locations where they're located
and so if i want to see a breakdown of
everything in the overview i can
certainly do that if i go to locations
under real time i could see a majority
of my users are coming from the united
states okay where are they coming from
i'll just click on traffic sources and
here i could see the different sources
and mediums medium is the means in which
the traffic was driven so if it's google
it's either paid search or organic
search so i can see here it's organic
then i can actually see what content
they're looking at on my website so i
could see currently have three active
users on the home page two active users
on the google's women's white tee page
so forth and so on now most importantly
if you have event tracking set up so if
you taking a look at our google tag
manager webinar you know that you could
set up event tracking in google
analytics to measure engagement on your
website whether that be a form
submission or somebody clicking on the
play button of a video so if i click on
events i'll be able to see what events
are firing so here i can see we have
event tracking set up and i can see how
many different events are firing on my
website in real time so here i can see
e-commerce somebody clicking on the
quick view click some a couple of users
clicking on add to cart a couple of
users clicking on the promotion click
and as these events are fired you're
gonna be able to see them highlighted so
if something gets fired it's going to
get highlighted and i could see
that these are the current events that i
have currently firing on the website and
that's what's currently fire now if i
want to look at the events that have
happened in the last 30 minutes i can
just click on this link here last 30
minutes and it's going to give me an
overview of the events that have
happened over the past 30 minutes okay
so that's event tracking and then more
importantly we can also look at what
conversions are happening in real time
just by clicking on conversions and so
now i can see
i had one active user who entered the
checkout so that's goal number four so
in analytics you can have up to 20 goals
and so here i can see we have goal
number four has already had one active
user and so if i look at the last 30
minutes i can see i still have only one
goal over the last 30 minutes and that
was somebody who entered the checkout so
that's real time reporting in summary it
just gives you an idea of what's
currently happening on your website and
so for me ideally if i'm launching a
campaign or let's just say you do a new
website redesign and you want to see how
users performing and behaving then real
time is a good option for you so you can
see how things are happening in real
time now let's jump down to audience
reporting so if i click on audiences
it's just right underneath real time i'm
going to see a number of different
reports available to me under audience
and so let's click on the audience
overview report so
audience reporting basically allows us
to get a sense of who is coming to our
website when i say who is coming to our
website it doesn't necessarily have to
be a specific person in fact google
doesn't allow personally identifiable
information in google analytics personal
identifiable information such as a
specific name a social security number
credit card information etc however we
could still paint a nice picture on who
is coming to our website meaning what
country
city or state did they come from what
language what device did they get to our
website from how old were they okay were
they male or female or other what
interest did they have what browser did
they use so we can paint a nice picture
based on all this information that
google analytics is providing us under
audience so if i go to audience overview
here i can see i have all these
different options available to me to get
a basic understanding of who is coming
to our website so for example i could
see a majority of the people coming to
our website speak english and are from
the united states okay in fact that
represents 61
of the users and so google analytics
does a great job of giving me an overall
percentage so if i have a 100 of the
users i could see 61 percent of those
users represented english-speaking users
from the united states seven percent
represented english-speaking users from
great britain and so when it comes to
analytics we have users and users are
broken down into two categories they're
either returning or they're new so when
you add the google analytics tracking
script to your website what's going to
happen is if a user or when a user goes
to your website they're going to get
cookied if it's the first time they've
been to your website what google
analytics is going to do is store a
cookie in the browser so when that same
user comes back another day in the same
browser analytics is going to recognize
that that cookie is in the browser and
so then analytics is going to categorize
that user as a returning user okay so
that's how analytics is able to
differentiate new versus returning so if
that user doesn't have a cookie in the
browser then analytics is going to
recognize that store the cookie and then
count that user as a new user and so
when you're looking in analytics you're
going to be able to see a breakdown of
new versus returning so here i can see
over three quarters of my traffic over
the past week here i can see april 6
through april 12th three over three
quarters are new users to the website
here i could see about 23 24
are returning users okay so i can get a
good breakdown of what type of users are
coming am i driving new traffic am i
driving traffic that's been to my
website before what language are they
speaking okay i can also paint a bigger
picture how old are they are they what
gender are they do they come from mobile
so let's take a look at some of these
different reports under audience so if i
skip down now to demographics i can
click on overview and when that report
loads i can see now under demographics
overview i can see the breakout of age
ranges and so here i can see the
majority of the traffic coming to my
site again over the past week now if i
want to change this date range i could
simply do that i can change the date
range just by clicking on the date range
and then maybe going say the last 30
days and i can even compare it to the
previous period or the previous year i'm
going to choose the last 30 days i'm
going to click apply now i'm looking at
data over the last 30 days and again you
can change the date range to any range
you want you can only go back as far as
when you actually created the google
analytics account you can't go prior to
that so here i'm looking at the last 30
days and i can see almost 47
of my users were in their age range of
25 to 34. now when it comes to gender i
can see
represent males so i can get a breakout
of gender and age as well as interest
and click on interest and look at the
overview there and see what the interest
is of the users who are coming to my
site based on in-market segments or
affinity i can also choose language and
location so if i want to know exactly
where my users are located when they're
coming to my website i can click on
location and here i can get a breakout
43 percent of the users of the last 30
days were from the united states more
importantly i can align my audience with
goals and we'll talk about goals here in
a minute but here i can see if i have an
e-commerce website i can see of those 43
percent 0.29 of those converted or
purchased something and that equates to
94 transactions so i can get a good
sense of not only how many users are
coming from a specific country but are
those users converting if i click on
mobile and mobile to me is one of those
reports i tend to spend a bit of time on
because i want to know what devices
users are coming to my website and so
for my website here or this is the
google demo website i can see mobile
represents approximately 27
of the traffic so desktop still
represents a majority of the traffic so
for you you want to keep an eye on
mobile because mobile is definitely a
majority of what people use nowadays
that's how people start their day that's
how they transact via mobile whether
that's purchasing something
communicating or searching it all starts
with mobile so you want to keep an eye
on mobile and more importantly you want
to keep an eye on behavior so google
analytics is telling me that yes i have
approximately 27 of my traffic of the
last 30 days came from mobile how are
they interacting with my website so if i
look across this report i'm going to be
able to see different metrics so if i'm
measuring specific metrics against my
dimension in this case the dimension is
what we're measuring and in this example
we're measuring mobile i can see that
the bounce rate is approximately 48
and bounce rate means that if a user in
this case from mobile landed on a page
they
left the site without going any further
so they consider it a bounce if they
don't go to another page if they leave
the site from the page they landed on
and they don't go any further that's
considered a bounce so bounce rate is
the percentage of people who come to the
site and leave the site without going
any further so in this case we have 48
bounce rate that's almost half of our
users who come from mobile leave the
website from the page they landed on so
is that good is that bad well it's open
to interpretation is definitely
subjective but you want to keep the
bounce rate as low as possible you want
to keep people on your site especially
if you have an e-commerce website you
want people who come to your website to
purchase and so here we can see 48
mobile in desktop it's a little bit
lower at 41
now if i look a little bit further at
engagement i can see how many pages on
average do mobile users look at so
versus desktop it's a little bit lower
you can see 3.86
on desktop it's 4.5
now if i look a little bit further in
engagement i want to be able to measure
how long somebody from mobile stays on
the website if they're bouncing at 48
but they're also looking at 3.8 pages
3.9 almost four pages per session then
that means in this report analytics is
telling me they're spending about two
minutes on the site and interestingly
enough i can see that mobile over the
last 30 days
had more transactions so 51 transactions
versus 34 transactions from desktop and
interestingly enough the commerce
conversion rate is at 0.29 percent
that's higher than desktop at point zero
seven it's lower than tablet but it's
higher than desktop and mobile has the
most transactions and since they have
the most transactions they have the most
revenue at two 2 380. so
yes the engagement isn't exactly as
great as it is as desktop but we can see
that people are still purchasing with
their mobile devices so it's something
to keep an eye on and mobile is
something i definitely look at in fact
since it's such an important report one
thing you can do in analytics is if you
actually like a report and you think
you're going to look at that report
multiple times then you can simply just
go ahead and click save at the top here
so if i click save i'm going to enter a
name for this report i'm just going to
call it mobile report and click ok and
then what's going to happen is it's
going to be located under save reports
and save reports is located under
customization customization is located
above real time okay so if i close that
up you can see audience real time
customization if i click on
customization if i click on save reports
i should be able to see my save report
here and i do so here i can see mobile
report if i click on it i can simply go
to the report i was looking at before i
saved it so save reports to me is a good
feature in analytics because it allows
you to quickly access a report that
you've saved in the past so let's take a
look at one more report under audience
and let's go to benchmarking so remember
when we were setting up our analytics
account we had the option to opt into
benchmarking and i recommended you do so
and so if you did actually opt into
benchmarking then you're going to be
able to see
how your site
compares to others in the same industry
so if i click on benchmarking and then
click on channels what i'm actually able
to do now is compare my website with
others in the same industry so if i go
back to say jobs in education and i
choose education all education as my
industry vertical i should be able to
see
websites that are in the same particular
industry and how i compare with those
websites so i'm choosing all countries i
can narrow that down if i wanted to i
can just search for the united states i
can choose a specific state and then i
can choose a particular site size so
here i'm choosing sites by daily session
so these are sites that have an average
of 5 000 to almost 10 000 sessions a day
and so in this vertical education in the
united states sites that have 5 000 to
99999 sessions per day that means that
there are approximately 310 web
properties contributing to this report
okay based on this criteria i chose now
if my site is similar meaning if i'm in
the united states if i'm in education
and i'm receiving 5000 to
99999 sessions per day then i'm able to
compare my site against 310 other
websites now google's sharing this data
anonymously from the other websites and
they're doing the same with your website
to those particular websites
benchmarking reports okay so it's shared
data anonymously in particular
industries and verticals and so now i'm
looking at a channel report so if i want
to see how i compare to others in my
industry then i can go ahead and see by
channel for example am i driving as much
traffic as others in my industry and you
can see i'm not in fact i'm 76 77
percent worse in terms of the amount of
traffic
being driven from organic search so
anything in red is going to show as a
negative result a negative comparison
whereas something in green is a positive
comparison so if i look at engagement i
can see that i might not be driving as
much traffic but i can see that the
pages per session are better than the
site average or the industry average i
can see if i go over again looking just
at organic search i can see the bounce
rate is better than the industry average
so the channel report under benchmarking
allows you to measure how you compare to
others in your industry and you could do
so by looking at location and devices so
if you opted into benchmarking when you
set up your account then you'll be able
to compare your website against others
in your industry in your country region
and based on the size of your website in
terms of how many visitors or sessions
you're getting per day so let's go from
audience to acquisition so if audience
is who is coming to your website
acquisition allows us to see how the
traffic was driven to your website so
how did these users get to our website
and so under acquisition if we click on
overview we'll be able to see an
overview of how users whether they're
returning or new came to our website and
so what analytics does by default is
they have a number of default channels
and when we say channels we mean
analytics is grouping different channels
based on how users got to your website
meaning how did users get to our website
did they come via organic search meaning
did they type something into google and
find you in the organic listing
analytics also groups users based on
whether they came to your site directly
meaning did they type in the url
directly into the browser or did they
bookmark your website and come back via
the bookmark so they're grouping users
under direct they also group users under
referral meaning do they come from
another website they group users by
social do they come from a social media
platform like twitter or facebook if
you're running paid search
meaning if you're running paid search on
say google then do they come from paid
search ads now if you're running display
ads on say google's network google's
display network that's a default channel
so analytics will group users there so
if they don't recognize a channel then
they're going to group it as others so
by default google analytics groups users
on how they came to your website via
these default channels and so i can see
how many users came to the site from
each channel now if i want to drill down
on this report i can click on all
traffic and then if i click on all
traffic i can go to channels i can look
specifically at the channels report and
so now i can see organic search again
over the last 30 days is the number one
channel driving traffic and they
represent approximately again you can
see this number here in parentheses next
to the raw number of users i can see
that number is about 56
so 56 of my traffic over the last 30
days came from organic search and so
those are the number of users again as a
metric you're also going to have
sessions and you'll see sessions a lot
as a metric so users are broken down
between new and returning so every time
a new or returning user comes to the
website basically what they're doing is
initiating a session so you can have a
user who can come back multiple times
every time they come back to the website
it's a session so session is simply the
start of somebody coming to your website
and the session ends when they leave the
website and so
just like we looked at with the
audience reports when it came to mobile
we can also look at engagement by
channel so just like mobile we looked at
bounce rate pages per session average
session duration we can do the same
thing here with our channel report more
importantly in addition to behavior we
can see conversions and since we're
running an e-commerce platform we could
see what the conversion rate is by
channel so organic search did drive the
most traffic and they did have the most
transactions over the last 30 days and
the conversion rate in this case is 0.17
okay so how google determines the
conversion rate they basically take
the number of transactions and divide
that by sessions so that means that over
the last 30 days organic search drove 38
123 sessions and of those 38 123 64
actually turned into a transaction which
equates to 0.17 which also equates to 3
000 in revenue so i'm able to determine
not only how users are getting to my
website by looking at the channel report
i can actually see if they're engaging
and if they are converting and notice
when you look at a report in analytics
you can look at it by channel you'll
also get a summary so here i can see a
summary or a total based on my date
range so i could see over the last 30
days i've had 54 000 users 49
000 of them were new okay that meant
that at those 4 54 000 users i had 70
000 sessions i could see my average
bounce rate was 43
the pages per session were just over
four and the average session duration
how long did somebody stay on my website
on average about two minutes and 55
seconds the average conversion rate was
0.14 and i had a total of 97
transactions totaling 5500
okay and that's all over the last 30
days so any report you look at in
analytics is gonna have a summary and
note that any report you look at in
analytics is going to allow you to save
it so if it's a report you think you're
going to go back and look at at a future
date then you simply just have to click
on the save button conversely if you
don't want to save it you can simply
just export it so you can export it as a
pdf if i click on pdf it's going to
allow me to export that as a pdf now you
have other options available to you as
well you can do a google sheet you can
export it as an excel or you can export
it as a comma delimited file so here you
can see i can save it as a pdf if i want
to and if i click ok it's going to save
to my desktop or location of my choosing
and then i can go back and look at it in
that format at a later time so that's
the export feature available to you in
analytics again if you you could save it
as well or you can export it okay some
other reports under acquisition if
you're running google ads note that you
can connect google ads to analytics and
this is key because now i can see
how many people are coming from google
ads to my website and are they
converting now this is important because
with google ads i'm actually paying for
the click so you can see here i'm
running a report based on campaign data
so i could see what campaigns are
driving traffic how much of pain per
click and you can see on average i'm
paying 34 cents per click and then more
importantly i want to be able to see if
they're converting so you can see i've
spent 810
over the last 30 days and received 858
in revenue so you want to make sure that
you link up your google ads account to
your google analytics account for this
very reason you want to be able to see
how your google ads campaigns perform
once the users get to your website and
so i want to see if they're engaging and
i want to see if they're converting so
there are all sorts of reports under
google ads so you can look at it by
keywords by search queries by hour of
the day if you're running display
campaigns you can look at display
targeting so there's all sorts of
reports under google ads you just have
to link it up and you link it up under
the admin now there are other reports
that you can look at so if i go to
campaigns i can look at all campaigns so
if you're running all sorts of different
types of campaigns whether that be on
facebook whether it be email whether
that be you know other types of
advertising let's just say twitter or
instagram you're going to be able to see
those campaigns here and that's under
all campaigns and again you'll be able
to see the campaign name and you'll be
able to see metrics associated with
those campaigns and more importantly
you'll be able to see your e-commerce if
you run an e-commerce platform or if you
have goals set up so you'll be able to
look at how your campaigns are not one
not only driving traffic but two are
they converting let's go from
acquisition reporting to behavior so
behavior reports are going to actually
show you
how users behaved once they got to your
website once they landed on a page on
your website how did they behave so when
we looked at audience we got a sense of
who is coming with acquisition we get a
sense of how the traffic got to our
website did they come from organic
direct social etc the behavior reports
allow us to actually measure how that
traffic behave once they landed on a
page on our website and so if i go to
overview under behavior now i'm looking
at this graph here it's showing me how
many page views i've had and a page view
is simply once a page is viewed it's
counted as a page view so if a user
comes to my site they're initiating a
session and if they look at a page then
that page is going to have a page view
okay so a user can look at a page
multiple times in a session and every
time they look at that page it's going
to count as a page view so here i can
see in this graph how many page views
i've had again over the last 30 days and
if i look further at my overview report
i can see the specific pages and how
many pages they've had and i can also
look at some other metrics okay the
average bounce rate the average time on
page i can look at the exit rate which
means how many people actually exited or
the percentage of people who exited from
that page so i can dig deeper into my
behavior reporting so if i click on site
content and i click on all pages then
i'm going to look at a report by page
this is my dimension this is what i'm
measuring my page and now i can see how
many page views each page had over the
last 30 days now note you also have
something called unique page views so
unique page use is equivalent to one per
session in other words if a user came to
my site and looked at the home page then
the home page is going to have one
unique page view and one page view now
if the user in that same session looks
at other pages then every page that user
looks at is going to have one unique
page view however if the user goes back
to a to the same page in the same
session then it's still going to be one
unique page view but in this case the
home page if they look at the home page
a second time then the home page is
going to have two page views if they
look at the home page five times in one
session then the home page is gonna have
five total page views and one unique
page view okay so that's why unique
pages is equivalent to one per session
where page uses accumulation of how many
times the page was viewed in the same
session so in other words you're always
going to have more page views than
unique pages okay so this gives me a
sense of how my page is performed so
again i can look at total page views and
then engagement so ideally what you want
to do with a report like this is if a
user is not engaging on the page then
that should tell you something about the
page itself if they're not engaging if
the bounce rate's high if the time on
page is low if the exit percentage of
exit rate is high then you probably want
to do something with that page now these
are all pages but if i jump down to
landing pages my landing page report is
showing me how many people actually
landed on that page and so here i can
see under my landing page report i can
see the home page had 36 000 17 sessions
in the last 30 days that's how many
people landed on the home page so here i
can see 71 percent were new sessions
meaning that i had a lot of new users
who landed on the home page in fact 25
000 or 52
of the people who landed on the homepage
were new i could see the balance rates
about 42 percent but of those who didn't
bounce they went on to look at about 4.5
pages per session and spent about three
minutes on the site and the one thing i
like about the landing page report is i
can also see
whether that particular page in this
case the home page did it help
contribute to a goal or conversion and
in this case i can see of those 36 000
sessions i had 22
transactions totaling 1200 in revenue
and that's an e-commerce conversion rate
of 0.06
so the home page over the last 30 days
contributed to
0.06
of the revenue so this gives you an idea
of when somebody lands on your website
and they land on a page is that page
helping to move that person along
meaning are they not bouncing and is
that page helping to move people towards
converting and so that's what the
landing page in effect allows us to
measure is the engagement and in this
case we're measuring transactions okay
so analytics also gives us some other
reports under behavior including site
speed so site speed to me is an
important report to look at just like
the mobile report to me site speed's
important because what google analytics
does is they take a sampling of pages
and in this case you can see over the
last 30 days they sampled
2835 page views and of that sample they
came back and said the average page load
time is about four seconds now ideally
you want to keep it as quick as possible
i would say even under three seconds
okay now there are other factors
involved with page load time the browser
you're using the country that you're
actually browsing that page from might
not have the best infrastructure you
name may not even be on the best
internet network meaning you're on a
cell network or the wi-fi is not that
great or you can be on a page that just
has a lot of images or a lot of code
that may slow it down so there are other
factors involved and so what google
analytics does is show you what those
factors are so here i can see by browser
what the average load time is if i want
to look at country i could see what
country is contributing to the low time
now the great thing about the site speed
report is if i go to speed suggestions
okay what speed suggestions is going to
do is it's going to show me the page
load time by page and then it's actually
going to provide a link where i can
actually click on to get suggestions on
increasing the page load time so for
example i can look at this particular
page here this google redesign shop by
brand slash youtube page line number
five if i look at line number five i can
see the average load time of this page
is eight seconds almost nine seconds
okay that's an eternity to some people
now notice this link next to it so
google is recommending seven total
suggestions so if i click on seven total
what it's actually gonna do it's gonna
open up a new window
and it's going to open up another google
report called page speed insights and
page speed insights is going to give me
some information about what i can do to
create crack correct the page load of
that particular page so look at this
site speed report it's important because
there is a correlation between site
speed or page load time and user
behavior of that page and there's also
correlation between page load time and a
page ranking organically on search so
page load times very important it's so
important that i'm even going to save it
so i'm going to click save and click on
speed site speed suggestions as my name
and click ok and now that report is
going to be saved under customization
under save reports let's jump from
behavior to conversions now conversion
reporting is arguably the most important
section in google analytics because what
the conversions reporting allows us to
do is see how people are converting or
if they're not converting on our website
and so in google analytics we have the
opportunity to set up goals now you have
the opportunity to set up 20 goals in
your google analytics view and so to set
up a goal okay so you're going to click
on admin and under the view you're going
to see goals and so if you don't even
have goals the first step is to create
goals and so you have four different
goal types and analytics so you have
pages per session so how many pages per
session is so if your goal is set to say
three or two if somebody actually looked
at two or three pages per session it's
going to count as a goal okay so if i
look here i could see i have pages per
session set at 10. so that means that if
a user came to the site looked at more
than 10 pages per session then it's
going to count as a goal another goal
type is destination so destination means
that if somebody actually went to a
specific page then it's going to count
as a goal and in this case i can see
here
that the goal is set to this particular
page here and so when somebody actually
lands on that page it's going to count
as a goal now there are two other goal
types we can look at one is duration so
just like pages per session in our
previous example if somebody looked at
10 pages per session it's going to count
as a goal with duration it's based on
time so in this particular case if you
set up a duration goal and the duration
is set to say 1 minute and 30 seconds
then that means if a user comes to my
website and they spend at least one
minute and 30 seconds then it's going to
count as a goal okay and then the fourth
type of goal in google analytics is an
event based goal so when you set up
event tracking you could turn that event
into a goal so if somebody clicks on say
the submit button of a form you can turn
that event into a goal so here you can
see the category equals contact form so
you can always verify if a goal works
just by clicking on verify this goal and
in this case this event is turned into a
goal so anytime somebody fires this
event it's gonna count as a goal so you
have four different goal types in google
analytics you have pages per session
destination event and duration and so
once you've set up a goal then you can
measure goals under conversions so now
if i look at goals overview i can be
able to see how many total goal
completions i've had so if i want to
look at it by goal i can just choose the
goal option here so if i want to look at
for example
goal 2 engaged users this was the pages
per session i can see that i had a
conversion rate of 10
meaning that i had 7 000 of all the
users who came to the website 7 000 gold
completions meaning seven thousand one
hundred six users looked at ten pages or
more on my website and so that's how you
wanna be able to measure whether users
wherever they're coming from whoever
they are whatever pages they look at you
want to be able to look at the
conversion reports to see if they're
actually converting based on the goals
you've set up whether that's pages per
session duration destination or event
goal conversion tracking reports can
help you measure
who is actually converting and the great
thing about google analytics here is
that i can actually see
by segment so the default segment in a
segment is just looking at a specific
user set so the default segment is
always all users however i can choose a
different segment so if i want to choose
instead of all users if i want to choose
mobile traffic i can select mobile
traffic hit apply so i'm actually now
looking at a subset of data i'm looking
at mobile traffic so if all the mobile
users have come to my site i can see
1400 engaged or looked at 10 pages or
more okay and that's a 7
conversion rate so the great thing about
google analytics is you have the
opportunity to set up four different
goal types okay based on those goal
types you can go to goals overview and
look at the conversion rate of each goal
but you can also change the segment of
that particular goal to see who exactly
converted okay another report i like
under conversions is the multi-channel
funnel report so if i click on
multi-channel funnel basically what this
allows me to do is see how different
channels work together to convert so
remember the channel reporting we looked
at under acquisition here i can see now
how different channels work together to
drive the conversion so if i look at
three channels direct organic and
referral i can see all three together
drive two percent of the conversions if
i look at direct and referral twelve and
a half percent if i look at direct and
organic twelve point two four percent so
i can see how different channels work
together and so if i look at top
conversion paths as an example i can
actually see
what channels how channels work together
to drive the conversion so in this
example i can see over the last 30 days
that my top channel grouping was direct
times two meaning that somebody came to
the website directly meaning they typed
in the url in the browser or they
bookmarked it and came to the site okay
they came the first time but didn't
convert but then they came back a second
time via direct and then converted so
that combination is my top conversion
combination of the last 30 days my
second best conversion grouping is
organic search and direct meaning that a
user came to the website via organic
search first did not convert and then
came back via direct the second time and
converted so basically what analytics
does is give credit to the last referral
meaning if you came to the website via
referral or referring website and
converted then the referring website's
gonna get the credit for the conversion
but analytics does a good job of showing
you how different channels work together
so a channel may drive a lot of traffic
like organic search but that traffic may
not convert the first time around for a
number of different reasons whether it
could be brand recognition price
shopping reading content whatever the
case analytics is able to measure
if that channel actually did contribute
at a later point and in this case we
could see organic search drove traffic
that didn't convert but that traffic
came back a second time via direct and
did convert so that's our second best
channel grouping and so the
multi-channel funneling report top
conversion pass to me is a good report
to look at so you can actually see not
only a channels work together but you
can see sources and mediums and
campaigns and how all that all those
different campaigns from different
sources work together to convert so
that's just a good report to look at
there are so many different reports
available in analytics there's so many
that we haven't even gotten to yet so my
advice if you look at the demo report
you can get a feel for each of these
reports under each section whether that
be audience acquisition behavior or
conversions take a look at these reports
see what makes sense to you see what you
can use to improve your website
performance now if you have any comments
or questions about any of the reports we
covered feel free to comment underneath
this video we're definitely going to
have more webinars in the future about
specific analytics settings that we
didn't get to today and other types of
analytics reports and features that we
didn't get to today google tag manager
thanks for joining and let's get started
with this simply learn webinar so let's
start out with
ygtm so let's just say you're sam
and you have your own e-commerce website
and you want to understand how people
are interacting with your website well
sam today's world of websites contain a
lot of interactivity everything from
videos to pdf downloads to commenting to
form submissions uh to all sorts of chat
functionality interactivity going on
throughout the website so there's just a
lot that you need to track outside of
just page views and so
really what gtm does is they help you
track all these things i just mentioned
everything from somebody clicking on the
play button of a pdf to somebody
clicking on the submit button of a form
to somebody entering in something on a
chat function so that's what gtm is so
why gtm because it helps us track all
that interactivity so all gtm is is
really allows you to really place a
piece of java code which is just script
and the script that's added to a web
page to collect information so that's
really what a tag is it's just some
script that gets put on a web page in
order for you to collect information
like page views clicks etc and they send
it to third party tools okay so that's
what gtm does it basically allows you to
take all these tags that collect
information and you can use them in gta
so
if you want to for example collect how
many people
you know enter
a
chat functionality and start chatting
well you're going to take that script
and you're going to put it in gtm and
gtm will then allow you to start
tracking that information so that's
really what gtm is it just allows you to
put tags into a container or think of it
as a toy box you have all these toys and
you want to track well you can put all
those those toys or tags in a toy box or
container and we're going to talk a
little bit more about that but before we
get into gtm let's just say
you know you're communicating with your
developer and there's a new user request
on your webpage and you want to update
the tag well your developer considering
it's probably a small
update to your website he's probably
gonna not um hesitate and is gonna go
ahead and turn around and do it normally
and so normally what happens is the
developer's gonna go to the website and
update the tag well what if you have a
few things that you want to track all
those things i mentioned before from
downloads to clicks to
you know somebody checking out to
watching a video well your webmaster
your web developer is going to go well
hold on a second now all these requests
are going to take time i need to put
them into the work queue so to speak
well what happens is when they go into
work queue usually it's going to take
some time and
in some cases you as a marketer need to
launch a campaign and you want to get
that tracking
added to the website in time for the
campaign launch so you want to go ahead
and quickly turn around the tracking for
that particular campaign let's just say
you're launching a campaign and you're
sending people to a landing page that
has a form submission and you want to be
able to track how many people click on
the submit button of that form
submission well if you need to turn that
around your developer's like well i need
to put that in a work queue the timing
isn't going to always work out between
you and your developer is my point and
so that's where gtm comes in because
there is a solution update your tags
faster and that's google tag manager so
when we say gtm that's what gtm stands
for google tag manager it's a place for
you to add tags quickly and easily so
tags remember are just snippets of code
that allow you to track things on your
website interactively interactive
activity and
basically when you have gtm you can
bypass the webmaster and do it quickly
and easily so
that's what gtm is all about so why gtm
because we just identified two benefits
one you could track all the
interactivity on your website and two
you can bypass your web developer or
webmaster and so that's the benefit of
gtm so the benefit you get those tags
updated very quickly via google tag
manager okay so that's what tag manager
is so what we're going to talk about
today is specifically what tag manager
is and what it does we're going to list
some of the benefits of tag manager
we're going to show you how it works and
then we're going to show you how to get
started with tag manager tag manager if
you're not familiar with working with
webmasters and dealing with javascript
and tags and all this jargon is just new
to you today okay well don't fret sit
back we're gonna take it slow this is an
introduction into google tag manager
again let's start out with what is tag
manager so we've already introduced it
to some degree because we already
introduces a tool where you can put all
your tags into a toolbox toy box or
container so to speak right and we
already already mentioned that hey you
can bypass your webmaster so you're
probably thinking well if i'm if you're
not familiar with tag manager how can i
bypass my webmaster well first of all
it's a free tool and it's a google tool
hence the name google tag manager and it
helps you really that's the main point
is deploy and track tags on your website
by passing your webmaster so that's tag
manager and so examples of tags that can
be deployed vehicle tag manager are
numerous these are just some examples
like google analytics facebook pixel
tracking or google ads there's no limit
into the number of tags you can track in
tag manager there is no limit you can
add any number of tracking tags and tag
manager okay so some of the benefits
well again i we just listed two you can
put any tag into tag manager and track
that onto your website and we know you
can bypass your web developer or
webmaster and what it also does is it
also allows you to test and deploy your
javascript codes quicker so remember
these javascript codes or snippets of
codes are just there to track certain
things on your website whether that be a
page view or somebody clicking on a play
button or tracking somebody who converts
or even just goes to your website so the
biggest benefit is you can take that
snippet of code let's just say facebook
let's just say you're doing facebook
marketing and you want to put that
facebook pixel on your website so that
you could track people who come from
facebook and convert well you don't need
to put that facebook pixel on your
website you can go right to tag manager
and you can put that snippet of code
right in tag manager really quickly and
the other benefit here is all tags are
managed in one place and that's that to
me is really a good benefit because when
you start adding tags on your website
and you have some tags in tag manager it
just gets very confusing so ideally all
the tracking code you have on your
website needs to be in tag manager think
about that all the tracking so if you're
doing bing or you're doing facebook or
you're doing twitter or you're doing
linkedin and you're doing google you're
doing all this type of marketing on all
these different platforms you're going
to have tracking code for all these
different platforms and instead of
putting on that code on your website
return gonna slow down the sl load time
of your web page and website you want to
put them all in tag manager so they can
be organized and you know exactly what
you're trying to track and the other
great benefit of tag manager is there's
a versioning control so let's just say
you have added tags to your website via
gtm for the last six months well and
let's just say you add another tag
yesterday if you added that tag
yesterday and something doesn't work
well you can just roll back to a
previous version it's that simple so you
have versioning and that's that's a good
thing when you have versioning you can
control what gets published and if
something doesn't work after it gets
published then you can roll back to a
previous version so it's a a piece of
mind so to speak just because you've had
code to your site there's no guarantee
it's going to work and so you can always
control what version you're dealing with
in tag manager and we'll talk a little
bit more about that so the biggest
benefit here to me with tag manager is
you have event tracking and so we talked
about some of the things you could track
on your website from videos from play
buttons to somebody clicking on the stop
on the video or pausing it all the way
to somebody again chatting or let's just
say somebody clicking on that purchase
button on your website okay and you want
to track all these different things
these different interactivities and
buttons well event tracking is what
you're going to use to track all those
buttons and to me this is the biggest
benefit of tag manager and i'll show you
some examples as we go along and if we
didn't mention it already i'll mention
it again it is free tag manager is free
there's no limit so once you have tag
manager going you can add as many
tracking codes as you want there's no
limit on the number of tracking codes
you can add to tag manager okay so it's
free and you can use it to its fullest
advantage okay so it's also high
security meaning that it has different
levels of permissions okay so you can
have uh somebody just go in and look at
the different tags and tracking code you
have in gtm or you can have somebody who
is very familiar with tag manager and go
in and add the tracking code to tag
manager and then publish that tracking
code when it gets added so those are all
the benefits let's talk about how it
works now specifically how does tag
manager work because you're like rob
okay again a lot of jargon you know you
you got tags and javascript and and
versioning and publishing and all this
other stuff well i know i'm throwing a
lot at you at once but just bear with me
here okay so let's start talking about
how it actually works so you have a
website okay whatever that domain is you
have a website and there's chances are
on your website you have some form of
interactivity whether that be a video
whether that be a blog whether it be a
form submission you have a website with
some interactivity and let's just say
you're even thinking about getting ready
to launch some type of campaign on maybe
google or facebook and you want to drive
traffic to your website fair enough
you're joining the millions of other
websites that are out there that have
interactivity that also drive traffic to
the website so income's google tag
manager and so tag manager is important
because again we know we want to track
people coming from that facebook
campaign or that google campaign and
interacting with our site so if you are
running facebook and you are running
google analytics well guess what you
want to put that tracking code in tag
manager so google analytics being a
google product works very nicely with
tag manager facebook has its own
tracking code but you still want to be
able to track people who come from the
facebook campaign to your website so
you're gonna get that tracking code from
facebook and put it in tag manager
that's generally how it works so here
information from your website is shared
with another data source through tag
manager so think about that if i add
facebook tracking code to tag manager or
let's just say i had google analytics
tracking code to tag manager tag manager
is the one that's pushing out and doing
all the heavy lifting they're the ones
that are controlling what code gets
fired and what code doesn't so if you're
putting the code in tag manager tag
manager is controlling the code think
about it that way and let's show you an
example of what that looks like so here
i am i'm in tag manager i just went to
tag manager.google.com
and here i could see a list of tags so
in our conversation we're talking about
tracking facebook and we're talking
about tracking google analytics well
google analytics is easy because it's a
google product so here if i look at all
the different tracking code i have on my
website through tag manager let's just
take a look at google analytics so if
you're going to use tag manager you
might as well put the google analytics
code in here so here i can see i have
google analytics as a tag in tag manager
now for facebook if i'm running a
facebook campaign well i can take that
pixel tracking and put it in gtm as well
and here i can see facebook pixel that
is that code is added to gtm i just
basically took what facebook gave me and
put it into google tag manager so you
can see i can add facebook and google
analytics and again i can't stress it
enough any tracking code from any
platform i can add to google tag manager
in order to track the behavior from
those sources so let's take a little bit
deeper dive into how tag manager works
so i just showed you an example of how
you could take facebook and google
analytics code and put it into tag
manager but if you're not familiar with
tag manager then how do i do that well
let's talk about the structure and how
tag manager works so when you have a tag
manager account you have a container
remember i mentioned toy box earlier you
have a bunch of toys if they're their
code
and you're tracking different bits of
code from different platforms like
facebook think of those as toys and you
have a toy box okay well that's what
this code is and that's what a container
is the code is the code and that's gonna
go into the toy box or container and so
the way tag manager works is you have
tags triggers and variables so if i take
my facebook tracking code and put it
into a container i need to set up a tag
and a trigger okay so let's take a look
at what that is so first if i go back to
tag manager i'm going to have an account
and if i have an account i'm going to
have a container so here i'm just going
to click on an account with a container
and a container is nothing more than
what website you're adding the tracking
code to okay that's all the container is
we're just letting tag manager know this
is the website we're adding all this
code to so you have tags triggers and
variables that's the structure of tag
manager so tags are just what it says
tags what are we trying to quote unquote
tag well if it's google analytics that's
easy here i can see i have google
analytics added so if i click on google
analytics here's my tag and if i take a
little bit of a deeper dive there since
google analytics is a google product it
integrates already with tag managers
it's pretty easy i can just choose
google analytics then i'm going to check
page view and that's my tag now every
tag needs a trigger okay so i need to
tell tag manager how or when to fire the
google analytics tracking code so in
this case i'm gonna tell tag manager to
fire on all pages so if i get somebody a
visitor to my website analytics is
firing on all pages so whatever page
that visitor lands on google analytics
is gonna fire so that's really what it
comes down to is i have a tag and i need
to tell tag manager when to trigger that
tag that's really what the structure of
tag manager is it's tags triggers and
variables and variables what we're going
to talk about here in a couple minutes
but you have a piece of code you're
going to go ahead and put that into tag
manager you're going to tag it and then
you're going to fire that trigger so
let's take a look at another example
here if i go back here you can see
facebook well here's my facebook pixel
okay that's my tag so when is it gonna
fire well it's gonna fire on a specific
domain or subdomain that's basically
what we're doing we're trying to tell
gtm when to fire that particular tag so
those are the three main components a
tag okay which is going to contain the
javascript code that you get from say
facebook the trigger so you're going to
go into tag manager and tell tag manager
want to fire that code that's the
trigger and then you have variables and
so variables are basically just
additional information that tag manager
may need for your tag and trigger to
work so that's what a variable is it's
there to get the tag and trigger to fire
so variables are divided into built-in
and user-defined variables so common
used variables include say page path or
page url or hostname or click class
again they're there and these examples i
just gave you are there to get your tag
and trigger to work think about it that
way they're just that's a component and
if i go into tag manager here and here
on the left side i can see variables so
remember i have built-in and
user-defined
so built-in means that tag manager
already built these for me so in case i
need to get my trigger to work with my
tag i can use a variable so those are
built-in and then i have user defined so
these are what i define these are what i
created and again the variables are
there to get the tag and trigger to work
okay so that's the job of the variable
the job of the tag is to host that
javascript code okay in the case of
facebook or analytics that's where we're
putting our code so here if i click on
adwords remarketing again it's a google
product so i don't really need to even
deal with code i'm just gonna select
google adwords remarketing okay so you
can see gtm integrates nicely with some
of the other google products but let's
just say you have a facebook pixel
tracking code you're gonna choose custom
and you're gonna put the code here so
that's part of the tag and then the
trigger again is there to get the tag to
fire so you're telling gtm when to fire
the tag and the variable is there to
help you make sure that that trigger and
that tag work together so that's how all
three kind of work together you need the
tag to put the code you need the trigger
to tell gtm when to fire the tag in code
and the variables there to help you
define when that tag and trigger should
work or how it should work so again
review tags are they're just small codes
of javascript or tracking pixels on your
website and so tags are allowed to
manage events like scroll track and
remarketing clicks downloads files play
buttons you name it even clicks on
external links for example let's just
say you have a click uh or a facebook uh
icon on your site and when somebody
clicks on it they go to facebook you
want to maybe track that you're going to
create a tag okay the trigger is there
because you need to tell gtm when to
fire that tag so it's a certain
condition whether it's you know fire the
tag if the url
equals facebook.com or some other
condition so the tag cannot be created
until the creation of the corresponding
trigger so tags and triggers go together
you can't just create a tag and not have
a trigger otherwise your tag will never
fire and the variable was there again it
stores the information when defining a
trigger or transferring data to tag so a
variable has a variety of data okay so
you pick and choose the variable you
want to use with that trigger okay so
you're making sure that by defining a
variable you're making sure that you're
telling gtm how that trigger should be
fired so let's take a look at another
example here of how all three play
together if i'm in this account i'm in
this container if i look down here i can
see google optimize that's another
google product so
what i'm doing here is i just chose
google optimize as my tag it's already
integrated so what does that mean i
don't even need to deal with any code
i'm just going to select optimize well
we have the tag google optimize but we
need to tell gtm how to fire that and so
here we're going to tell gtm to fire it
on all pages so that's basically a very
simple example because we're firing it
on all pages so if i want to look at
something specific again facebook here's
my tag here's my code what's my trigger
well my trigger is it's going to fire on
specific pages how do i know that well
if i look at the trigger here i could
see the trigger is a page view but i'm
telling it to fire on this particular
hostname so the tag and trigger go hand
in hand
so how to get started with tag manager
so first things first you have to create
that account so you're going to go to
tag manager.google.com
or you can do a search for google tag
manager and you're going to create your
account and then when you create your
account what's going to happen is you're
going to
set up a container and when you set up a
container you have choices so you could
set it up for your website for an app on
ios or maybe android or you can even set
it up for amp etc an accelerated mobile
page so
most people by default are probably
going to set up tag manager for their
website and so when you do that when you
actually select website what's going to
happen is you're going to get some
google tag manager code in return and so
the whole idea here is you're going to
do a swap what you're doing is basically
you're saying okay google i'm going to
take this google tag manager code and
i'm going to put it on my website i'm
going to put it on every page in my
website so notice tag manager has two
scripts one goes in the head as high as
possible the other goes into the body
tag as high as possible and so what
you're doing is you're making a deal
you're putting this tag manager code on
your website and in return every code
you deal with whether that be facebook
or analytics or optimize or remarketing
or whatever it is is gonna go in gtm
okay it's gonna go into the container
you created so you need the tag manager
code on your website in order for tag
manager to work okay so when you add
this code to your website then you're
free to start adding all sorts of tags
to your container but if you don't have
this tracking code on your website then
none of the tags you add to your
container are gonna work so that's the
idea behind the container and then one
thing i wanted to mention on the account
is it's a google account so when you
create your account then make sure it's
the same account you use with say google
analytics or some other google product
that's a good best practice is always
use the same email address when you set
up your account so that it integrates
nicely across all the different
platforms meaning you can go from say
google analytics right to google tag
manager in one browser without having to
log out or log in okay so when you
create the account you're going to
create your container if you choose web
then you're going to be asked to place
code on your website and when you place
that code on your website then you are
free to start using tag manager and that
means you're free to start adding tags
so if you want to know more information
about installing google tag manager then
what i would recommend is visit the
quick start guide website of gtm so
again if you're curious as to where that
code is located in google tag manager
well when you create an account and you
create a container that container is
going to have a specific id so if i
click on that specific id here's where i
can get my code okay so again
when i'm logged in to tag manager i'm
going to click on workspace but in the
top navigation i'm going to see my
unique gtm id if i click on that that's
where my code is going to be located and
so again your code needs to go in the
header and there's another script that
needs to go in the body and if you're
not sure how to add the code to your
website well you can always click on the
quick start guide here okay and that'll
take you to a quick start guide page a
reference page related to google tag
manager so let's talk about creating a
tag so once you get tag manager
installed i'm sure you're excited to get
going and create that first tag so let's
talk about how to create a tag in tag
manager so when you're in tag manager
all you need to do is basically you're
looking at all your tags if you click on
tag in the left side navigation you'll
see all your tags and there's a new
button there so you just click new and
so basically what you're going to do is
you're going to create your first tag
and so what i would recommend once you
get tag manager installed on your
website i would recommend setting the
first tag up as google analytics so that
will get you going with tracking page
views on your website when some when
somebody visits your website okay so
ideally that's what you want to do you
want to get google analytics as your
first tag and tag manager so what i'm
going to do is because analytics is a
google product it's already integrated
nicely with tag manager so i'm just
going to click on google analytics it's
going to be a page for you that's what
i'm tracking and now i have to set up a
variable and so what it's going to do
it's going to ask me to sort of select a
variable and so what you're going to do
is you're going to select new variable
and what you're going to do is you're
actually going to go and add your
tracking id here that's going to be your
variable so where do i get my tracking
id and analytics well if i'm in
analytics i'm going to go to admin
and then under property settings i'm
going to see my tracking id and all you
need to do then is go to tag manager and
paste copy first you got to copy over
that tracking id then you're going to go
to tag manager and paste it and then
that's going to create a variable for
you and then when you create that
variable you're going to see it in the
drop down here so i've already created
it and
basically that's your tag with a
variable then what are you going to do
you're going to set up a trigger so see
i have some triggers already set up
you're going to see a default trigger
already set up for you and that's going
to be all pages so ideally what you want
to do is you want to select all pages in
order for analytics to fire on all pages
so that's what we're doing we're setting
up a trigger we're basically telling tag
manager hey if i get a visitor to any
page on my website then i want you to
fire google analytics so that's
basically in summary how to set up your
first tag and my recommendation is your
first tag should be google analytics and
when you set up analytics you're gonna
have to set up a variable for the
tracking id and so you get the tracking
id again from admin property settings
copy and paste that tracking id over
save it you have your variable that
variable is going to be included in with
the tag then your trigger is going to be
all pages and there you go you have your
first tag you have your first variable
you have your first trigger so that's
basically what you want to do and once
you've added that tag once you've added
that trigger then the only thing you
need to do now is basically publish the
tag and so anytime you save a tag you're
going to go ahead and submit it so that
way it gets published so again what
you're going to do is let's take a step
back here you're going to choose new tag
you're going to choose analytics from
the drop down menu you're going to
choose page view then basically you're
going to add your tracking id so you can
set up the variable and then basically
that's what you need to do okay you're
going to add that tracking id and then
voila that's your tag with a variable
and then once you've done that then
you're going to click submit so when you
click submit you're basically saying hey
i want this tag to go live now this tag
and trigger and once you've done that
then analytics is ready to go and
anytime somebody goes to your website on
any page tag manager is going to fire
google analytics so the great thing here
is you have something called google tag
assistant and that's an extension that
works with chrome and so when you've
actually added tag manager to your site
or you have analytics running in tag
manager you can confirm if those tags
are firing properly so let's take a look
at how google tag assistant works okay
so if you just do a search for google
tag assistant you're gonna see here that
it's basically just an extension that
works in chrome and unfortunately it
only works in chrome browser it doesn't
work in any other browser so go ahead
and install that extension into chrome
and when you do that you're going to see
this nice icon here in your browser and
now if you go to any website and i click
on google tag assistant and i click on
enable okay so basically i'm loading
google tag assistant and now once i
refresh the page i can see that this
particular site has google tag manager
installed and not only does it have tag
manager installed i can see that it's
also has google analytics running i have
also google optimize running and i have
google ads remarketing tag running in
tag manager so that's what tag assistant
does it allows you to see
if one tag manager is on the site and if
it is great what other tags are firing
on this particular site so tag
assistant's telling me i have these
particular tags firing on that site and
they're firing within tag manager so tag
assistant is a great way to confirm if
one tag manager is on the site and two
what other tags are firing on the site
now another way you could confirm if tag
manager is firing on the site is you can
go into preview mode so even before you
submit and publish your tag and trigger
you can click on the preview mode so if
i click preview in tag manager so
basically that's going to put me in
preview mode and so what does that mean
well that means that now i'm free to go
to my website and see if those tags are
firing and so let's take a look at what
that looks like so if i go to the
website and just click refresh then
what's gonna happen is tag manager is
gonna load in preview mode just as you
see here okay so that's going to take a
second couple seconds to load up and now
what can i see in preview mode i could
see that i have gtm firing but i also
have some other tags firing on this page
remarketing i have google analytics i
google optimize i have some other tags
firing as well and so the preview mode
shows me what tags are firing on any
given page and i can also see what tags
did not fire okay so here i have a
number of tags already in gtm but they
didn't fire on this particular page so
let's just say i clicked on the donate
now button i'm still in preview mode so
i'm going to be able to see what tags
fired now i could see
i have a couple of tags that have fired
on this particular page and then i can
see what tags did not fire on this page
okay
so that's the preview mode you can use
the preview mode before you even submit
a tag and trigger to see if it fires and
that's the great benefit of tag manager
so if you're not sure if something's
going to fire or not then you can always
go into preview mode um and if you are
sure it's going to fire then you can go
ahead and submit it so you can leave
preview mode and just go ahead and
submit that particular tag and trigger
so here i'm going to leave preview mode
and now once i'm done and i'm sure the
tag is going to fire and go ahead and
submit all my changes that i've worked
on in terms of setting up tags and
triggers so that's really gtm in a
nutshell so i have my tags okay my tags
are just snippets of code that i'm going
to put in whether that be facebook or
vet tracking or any other google product
like optimize or page view then i have
my triggers my triggers are there to
tell gtm when to fire that tag and the
variables are there to help those tags
and triggers work together so remember
that particular variable we set up for
google analytics okay so here it is
right here because we want to tell gtm
what property to specifically fire in
google analytics so that's why we set up
that variable but there are all sorts of
variables google tag manager has built
in or variables already created for you
or you can specifically define a
variable so variables are there to help
the tags and triggers work together so
when you set up a tag you set up a
trigger you use a variable you can
always go into preview mode preview it
by going to the website seeing if it
fires if it fires then voila you can go
ahead and click submit and that will
publish the tag and trigger and you're
good to go that's pretty much how tag
manager works and again i can't stress
that there is an unlimited number of
tags you can add to tag manager there's
no limit so you got everything from
anything from google to non-google to
event tracking okay to facebook to
anything that you want to track you want
to be able to put into tag manager and
again there's versioning that's one of
the great benefits of tag manager so if
i want to go back to an older version i
can simply do that so here you can see
i'm on version 32. that's how tag
manager works and i can't stress that
you know tag manager is there to help
you track interactivity on the site
because if you have a site that's
interactive that has a video
that has a download button let's just
say
you know you have all sorts of
newsletter sign ups facebook youtube
buttons on your website just like this
website does and you want to be able to
track how many people click on that
particular button well you're going to
need tag manager and when you have tag
manager you're going to be able to track
all of these button clicks and
interactivity on your website today
we're going to talk about how to rank
number one on google so let's get
started and um let's go with the
scenario that you have a friend named
sam and he has a website where he sells
shoes but sam doesn't understand
why his website's not ranking number one
on google and so typically
ranked number one on google there are
some factors involved and those are
factors that are going to help sam get
his website ranked number one on google
so he can sell his shoes get traffic and
convert that traffic to conversions so
there are factors involved and so what
are those factors well it always starts
with keyword research so in order to
rank for a website where you sell shoes
or
you sell products other products like
clothing or food or
you're an automobile website you're a
mechanic it doesn't matter whether
you're selling to customers or selling
to other businesses you have to start
with the keyword research and so we're
going to go into really explicit detail
on how to conduct a proper keyword
research and then the second factor
involved is high quality content so in
order to rank high on google search you
need to have high quality content so
we're going to go over
what's involved with creating high
quality content then we're going to
take that content we're going to
optimize it using on page elements and
website level factors so we're going to
take into account what's involved with
your website and what's involved with
specific pages on your website in order
to rank number one on google then we're
gonna get into the off-site engagement
so when it comes to ranking on google
you need to optimize your website and
you need to do
some elements off your website you need
to be engaging off your website meaning
on other websites and so we're going to
talk about what's involved with offsite
engagement so seo being a major channel
for most companies and websites where
the opportunity to drive a lot of
traffic is there but you have to earn
that reward the reward is a lot of
traffic but you have to earn the reward
there's a lot of work involved and so
ideally what we want to do is follow
what we call the 80 20 rule when it
comes to search engine optimization and
ranking on google and what do we mean by
the 80 20 rule well 80 20 means we're
investing 20 of our effort and 80
percent of the results are obtained so
we want to invest 20 and get back 80.
that's basically what we mean by 80 20.
so for example if 20 of our targeted
keywords bringing 80 of the traffic then
that's following the 80 20 rule or 20
percent of our landing pages drive 80
percent of the overall traffic that's
following the 80 20 rule or 20 of our
backlinks past 80 percent of our link
juice that's the 80 20 rule meaning
these targeted keywords these targeted
landing pages these trying to target
backlinks using off-site engagement we
want to put in 20 of our effort on those
keywords landing pages and backlinks in
return for eighty percent of the results
so without further ado let's get started
with the keyword research let's talk
about that keyword research for a
website with shoes and it doesn't really
matter
what particular product you have if you
need to rank number one on google it all
starts with the keywords as i mentioned
before and so
in this example if you have a website
where you sell shoes for kids you're
going to want to be found for certain
keywords so
the obvious key word here would be shoes
for kids well every keyword that you
target has search volume associated with
it so that means when we talk about
search volume we're talking about how
many people on average type in that
keyword or related keyword on google.com
or google search and there's always an
average number of searches associated
with every keyword and we call that
search volume how much search volume so
obviously if we're going to target a
keyword we want to have as much volume
as possible however there's always going
to be competition for those keywords
meaning there's always going to be other
websites who want to rank number one on
google for the same keywords and we call
that competition or difficulty so for
every keyword you're going to have
volume and you're going to have
competition or difficulty and the
difficulty ranges as well depending on
the tool you use and we'll get into that
in a minute but search volume is how
much on average people are typing in
that keyword or close variance of that
keyword and the difficulty is measured
in terms of how many other websites are
trying to rank for the same keyword and
so ideally when it comes to keyword
research we want to find that nice
balance we want high volume and we want
low competition but at the same time we
want to focus on keywords that are
highly relevant to our business so if
we're selling shoes for kids and shoes
for kids is highly relevant has high
volume and low competition then that's a
keyword we want to target so we always
want to focus in on those three areas so
there's always a trade-off with keywords
so shoes for kids might have high volume
but also might have high competition or
difficulty if we look for another
keyword that's just as relevant for
example shoes for children it may still
have high search volume but the
competition or the difficulty may be
lower and if that's the case then that
may be a better keyword for us to target
instead of something highly competitive
like shoes for kids we can focus on
another relevant keyword like shoes for
children with just as much volume and
lower competition and the reason why we
want lower competition is because we
want to be able to rank for that keyword
so the higher the competition the harder
it is for us to rank number one on
google for that keyword and so the whole
idea beyond keyword research is
analyzing and choosing the best keywords
so we want to identify a list of
keywords that are always relevant we
want to choose the keyword that your
competitors are ranking for and we want
to use third-party tools to choose
keywords to identify which keywords have
low competition and what keywords have
high search volume so one thing to take
into consideration when you're doing
keyword research is that the longer the
keyword phrase or in other words long
tail keywords or keywords with three
keywords in the phrase or more you're
going to always have less competition
but there's always a trade-off with long
tail keywords meaning the longer the
keyword phrase there's gonna be less
volume but the trade-off is less
competition and so what we want to do is
we want to brainstorm some ideas and
find those relevant keywords so let's
look at an example here so if we go to
google ads so google ads has a tool
called keyword planner and let's just
say i have a a website where i'm selling
dried figs and if i'm selling dried figs
i want people to buy these dried figs
however in order to attract them i want
to be able to show them that hey we have
a bunch of recipes and if i show you a
bunch of recipes where you can use dried
figs maybe you'll buy these dried figs
to use in these recipes and so we're
going to look for
keywords related to bread recipes
because if we can optimize for our
recipes page for bread then that will
attract an audience who wants to make
bread and use dried figs with those
bread recipes so that's the example i'm
going to give here and so if i look at
the keyword planner in google ads if i
just type in bread recipes what google
is going to do is they're going to give
me an average monthly search volume so i
can see the average monthly search
volume here is 60 500. and so in order
to do keyword research what i would
recommend is keep a spreadsheet and so
the idea behind the spreadsheet is to
document the volume and the competition
you're getting for certain keywords so
if i go into a spreadsheet
here my theme of keywords is bread
recipes my keyword is bread recipes and
my volume therefore is going to be 60
500. however if i go back into google's
keyword planner google's telling me the
competition is low so that's great i
want high volume i want low competition
but how low is low so we want to be
careful so if we're going to put in
numbers into a spreadsheet we want to
figure out what that competition really
is for the keyword bread recipes so if i
go to google and just type in bread
recipes i'm going to be able to see
771 billion results for the keyword
bread recipes now is 771 billion are
real competition maybe maybe not what we
want to do is put in a syntax and we
want to put in the syntax all in title
and then colon space and then our
keyword and the reason why we do that in
search is because we want to be able to
identify the true competitive number or
the true number of websites who are
trying to rank for bread recipes and if
we put in the syntax all entitled colon
and then our keyword bread recipes we'll
be able to see that there are 998
000 results that's a lot lower than 771
billion so that means that 998
sites or listings have the keyword bread
recipes in the title tag and the title
tag is what shows up in the search
engine results and so if i look down and
scroll down here i can see bread recipes
on every one of these title tags so
title tag is an important element to
rank number one on google and we'll talk
about that in a few minutes but if we
understand that there are 998 000
results with bread recipes in the title
tag then this tells us that those are
the websites who are trying to rank
number one on google for that keyword
and therefore those are the websites we
need to jump over in order for our
website to rank number one on google and
so therefore i'm going to put in 998
000 in my spreadsheet as the competitive
number and so now i could see for the
keyword bread recipes i have 60 500 and
if my competition is 998 000 then my kei
or keyboard effectiveness index or in
other words the ratio of volume to
competition is six percent so that's
nothing more than volume divided by
competition so that tells me that my kei
or my ratio between volume competition
is six percent so remember we want more
volume than we want competition so
anytime you do a keyword research you're
going to find a number of different
relevant keywords so if i go back into
google's keyword planner if i typed in
bread recipes you could see that google
is going to give me a number of
different keywords related to bread
recipes let's just say i have another
keyword that i want to think about
optimizing for being ranked on google
for and that's banana bread recipe very
similar keyword as bread recipes except
it's a little longer tail now if i type
in banana bread recipe in google's
keyword planner now i can see the
average monthly search volume has
actually gone up it's 368 000. i can
also see the competition is low so those
are good signs so now i can see 368 000
i'm gonna go ahead and put that in my
spreadsheet now i'm going to go into
google i'm going to put in my syntax all
in title i'm going to put in banana
bread recipe i'm going to hit enter and
now i can see i have 233 000 results
with the keyword banana bread recipe in
the title tag so if i look at the title
tags i can see banana bread recipe
banana bread recipe banana bread recipe
on all the listings in the google search
results so that tells me i have 233
000 results that i have to jump over in
order to rank number one on google so
i'm going to put 233 000 in my
spreadsheet now i can see my kei or my
volume to competition ratio is 157 158
and so to me that's a lot better number
to work with or in other words that's a
lot better keyword because it's just as
relevant and it has a higher ratio of
volume to competition so therefore
banana bread recipe is going to be a
better keyword to optimize for in order
to rank number one on google so that's
the whole idea behind keyword research
you want to brainstorm ideas there are
plenty of tools out there so the tool i
recommend is google ads keyword planner
google is going to give you how much
search volume they're going to tell you
the competition but then you're going to
go into google search you're going to
use the syntax on title to get a more
accurate read on the actual competitive
number and so
to find out how keywords that your
competitors are ranking for you can use
those keyword tools that i mentioned
another tool that i use is miles so moz
if you go to moz.com
they have a tool called keyword explorer
so if we just type in the keyword for
example bread recipes it's going to be
able to tell us how much volume and the
difficulty so you can use other tools at
your disposal figure out the volume and
the difficulty there are plenty of tools
out there but the one thing i would just
make sure is you use everything at your
disposal so you can use social media to
find the most shared article for a
particular topic or keyword like bread
recipes you could check other platforms
that have a lot of shared content like
reading and quora where you can ask
people about certain topics using
keywords to figure out how much
competition or volume there might be you
can stay up to date on industry news to
get an idea of what types of keywords
are trending but when it comes to
keywords and keyword research remember
for every web page we want to be able to
pick two keywords we want a primary and
secondary keyword so when we do keyword
research and we enter all our keywords
into our spreadsheet we want to be able
to have a number of different keywords
in this case we're focusing on the theme
bread recipes we want to have different
keywords because we want to be able to
choose a primary keyword and a secondary
keyword because we want to be able to
focus on multiple keywords for each page
because we don't want to put necessarily
all our eggs in one basket maybe we
won't want to put our emphasis just on
one keyword to rank for we want multiple
keywords to try and rank for so the
primary key work and to find the nature
of our business the secondary keyword
could be just highly relevant to our
keyword at the end of the day we want to
choose multiple keywords to try and rank
on google for that page so for example
we have a blog and we're using ice cream
recipes and we're blogging about ice
cream recipes we can have a primary
keyword that is about ice cream recipes
or homemade ice cream recipes we're
going to always want to find out what
the volume and the competition is our
secondary keyword could be built around
other similar keywords like low-fat ice
cream recipes or fat-free ice cream
recipes or low-fat homemade ice cream
recipes those are complementary keywords
just like our bread recipes and banana
bread recipe so one thing we want to do
when we do keyword research is we want
to be able to target one keyword per
content when you can target many we want
to be able to target multiple keywords
not necessarily target one keyword and
so we want to be able to cluster
keywords so we don't want to target just
one we want to target multiple keywords
per page and when we talk about
clustering if we go back to
our keyword research what we're doing is
we're clustering a bunch of keywords
under the theme bread recipes and so by
looking at the volume looking at the
competition looking at the kei we can
choose different keywords for our page
and that's what we mean by clustering we
want to cluster keywords into a content
theme so why target only one keyword per
content when we can target many because
we don't want to put all our eggs in one
basket we don't want to target just one
keyword we want to target many and so
that means clustering your keywords into
a theme and choosing multiple keywords
for that particular page and when we do
that we have a better opportunity to
rank high on google search and the whole
idea behind ranking high on google
search is we can get the volume so if we
know we're ranked number one on google
search for bread recipes or banana bread
recipe we know we stand a chance of
getting a majority of the volume
associated with that keyword and if we
can get the volume and get the traffic
then we can get the conversions so let's
move on to high quality content and talk
about the impact content has on your
ability
to get your website ranked number one on
google so let's just say you have
content on your website and the content
is ranking on
you know page four of google and it's
that blog with ice cream recipes and if
it's just content for the sake of
content is not really informative then
it's not necessarily going to get good
engagement in the eyes of google you
know they want to rank content that's
very informative it's very fresh it's
exciting to read it's interesting it's
going to have good engagement so if it's
a recipe or an article about any topic
if it's the content is just not
informative then you're not going to get
good engagement and when you don't get
good engagement if people don't stay on
the site to engage in the content and
they just leave the website after
landing on the page causing a bounce
then the content is just going to
continue to fall down the rankings and
we want to prevent that we want to move
up the rankings we want to be number one
on google we don't necessarily want to
fall in the rankings for our content so
content is a key driver
in being able to rank number one on
google so if the content is on page nine
what can we do well we want to be able
to you know take that content and do
something with it we feel like we did
write engaging content so let's go ahead
and share it on social media and to me
social media is a good platform to share
your content because on social media
platforms like facebook for example
you're building a community on that
platform that community is already
interested in your content so if you're
sharing an ice cream recipe especially
in the summer time and you're engaging
with your community on that platform
then the likelihood of that community on
that platform is going to increase
engagement increased engagement will
send social signals to the search engine
that says hey this content is good
quality likewise for any other platform
most social media platforms have
engagement metrics and those engagement
metrics pass signals is it good is it
not good do we like this content are we
giving it a thumbs up are we going to
want to follow it are we going to want
to share it and so if you share content
that you feel is engaging on social
platforms then it's going to be engaging
and it's likely going to cause an
increase in engagement for example a
decrease and bounces and once you share
that quality content then the likelihood
of it moving up the rankings even as far
as number one on google is going to be
greater so you always want to start out
writing good quality content so let's
talk about good quality content because
google does take content seriously they
do take into account what other people
think of that content so high quality
content is an important factor so how to
create good content that's always the
question so let's talk about some best
practices here remember in the last
segment we talked about keyword research
so we want to perform good keyword
research why because we want to choose
keywords remember we're choosing
multiple keywords per page one keyword
could be related to our brand one
keyword could be related to the content
but another keyword could be related to
a user's intent like recipes if you
recall the example we use with bread
recipes maybe somebody's looking to type
in a keyword that says how do i make you
know a bread or how do i make a specific
type of bread or how do i make banana
bread or what's the best recipe for
banana bread they're question related
and we want to be able to answer those
questions so that's where choosing those
right keywords that's going to respond
to a user's intent so starts with
choosing the right keywords so
remember we talked about a number of
different tools when we talked about
keyword research so there's a research
tool that you can use called phrase.io
and that will help you do quick research
on you know keywords and trends and
whatnot so
if you know about a research tool that
you use for keyword research then drop
us a comment below i'd be interested in
getting your comments about keyword
research and what research tools are out
there so if you know something better
than phrase.io drop a comment below and
we'd be interested in getting your
perspective so keyword research is key
but creating content that fulfills users
requirements so answering those
questions it's a recipe we want to
answer that question if it's directions
we want to answer that question if they
don't know how to do something we want
to answer that question and that's the
whole idea behind content content is not
just to fill a page it's to really
fulfill users requirements that's when
you get good engagement so if somebody's
typing in something on google and
they're looking for an answer your
content should answer that question but
we also want to make the content
readable so in other words you know
write for your audience don't impress
anybody with very high
vocabulary type words that somebody
doesn't necessarily know the meaning of
don't use jargon don't use a street
language for example use everyday common
language that's just easily digestible
when your audience is reading and then
we want to keep that content organized
and so when we mean organized we want to
use headers and subheaders you know
break your content into paragraphs keep
the flow organized if we can keep the
flow organized then it's going to be
easier for somebody to read and then
it's okay to add resources especially
resources from credible sites so if you
can incorporate those resources in there
then it's just going to add the
credibility to your content let the
audience know that hey i've done my
research on this topic and this is what
this person has to say about it this
person who seems to be credible okay so
it only adds value to your content so
these are all tips to remember when
creating content and then the one
important tip here is we want to use
white hat techniques and when we say
white hat techniques that means you know
if we've chosen keywords that are going
to answer somebody's question we don't
want to stuff those keywords into the
content we want the content to be
naturally written so when we say opt for
white hat techniques that's what we mean
write the content naturally keep it
organized keep it readable include
third-party sources and make sure it
answers a question so they're different
types of content so there's content
where you just write words to install
text based you could also use an
infographic an infographic is simply
just a graphic that visualizes exactly
what you're trying to explain for
example if we want to
write an article about how to write good
engaging content we don't necessarily
have to write all that out as a text we
can create an infographic so for example
here's an infographic on 20 effective
ways to basically not bore your readers
but write engaging content so you could
see this is an infographic it's all
graphically laid out so infographics
tend to be easier to understand because
they're visual they're easy for the end
user to comprehend because there's
generally no jargon it's usually images
that are portraying the points of what
you're trying to get across and so it
tends to break it up the monotony of
just text it's more visually appealing
and it's laid out and organized so you
can see this infographic has 20
different steps or rules and they lay
those out all here in this infographic
and the great thing i like about
infographics is you could you could
share them on social media you can
re-engage them as a post you could save
them on really any social platform so
infographics tend to tell a better story
and versus say just writing text you can
use video and images so you don't
necessarily have to lay it all out in an
infographic you can certainly insert a
video or an image into
your content especially if it's a blog
post if it's a blog post then sometimes
video and images on its own
tell the story you don't necessarily
need text to
go ahead and tell your story a video or
an image as they say tells a thousand
words and so
images and videos are great to use in a
blog post so
using different forms of content you
know you always want to review your
content when a user dwells on your web
page for a longer time google will tend
to think okay this person is engaged so
we're going to rank that favorably so if
you're using
infographics videos and images then the
chances of somebody being more engaged
are going to increase versus just text
that's not well organized and written
out in a way that somebody doesn't
necessarily understand so be creative in
the types of content you use so longer
engaging content tends to bode well with
search engines so this is according to
hubspot so the more word count you use
the more words you use the chances of
you ranking higher are going to be
better just take into account best
practices you want to maybe break up the
content with an image organize it make
it engaging use headers so it's not
necessarily just words it's the words
and how those words are written how
they're structured the types of keywords
you're using how you're engaging with
your audience there's a lot of factors
again those best practices we just went
over but the key is you know if you have
longer more engaging content then it's
going to bode better for you on search
engines so a couple of steps to create
high quality content so you want to
begin with a comprehensive introduction
so always introduce your content
remember the content should be relevant
to the keywords so if you're choosing
keywords in your keyword research think
about answering that question if
somebody's typing in bread recipes maybe
they're looking for banana bread recipes
how to
make the best banana bread or how to
make banana bread using dried figs we
want to be able to align our content
with that keyword naturally you want to
create a title that's worthy that's
click worthy so remember if you're in
google search and you're doing search
for something simple like bread recipes
we want to
make something that's going to be you
know engaging for somebody to click on
like easy perfect yeast bread or easy
crusty french bread or something that's
going to be engaging you know the best
bread recipes or how to make the best
homemade bread you know something that's
going to draw somebody's attention to
the title of that blog post so we want
to include lsi keywords so what i mean
by lsi keywords in your content we mean
you know long tail keywords make it
natural headings and subheadings should
consist of keywords and variants so
if you're writing headers and subheaders
include the keyword in there and that
way the the content always stays
relevant to the audience okay shorten
your sentences and paragraphs so don't
write long paragraphs remember we want
to break this up we want to make it easy
for the end user to read and we want to
always put internal links on our blog
post why because if we have internal
links then if we have a link from one
blog post to another blog post or say
our blog post to an internal page on our
website we want to make sure that it's
relevant content that way somebody's
reading something and you have an
internal link let's just say from a
bread recipes page to
a banana bread recipes page then they
may find it interesting click on that
link and go to the banana bread recipes
page so it's keeping somebody engaged on
your website so putting in internal
linking will help keep the end user
engaged because you're offering up links
that's relevant to the content you
always want to break up that content
with images okay we want to use alt tags
meaning we want to
pen the image with text so that way the
image doesn't load then at least the alt
text will load so we can incorporate
call out boxes and more importantly we
want to update our content regularly so
we always want to
get the best recipe out there if it's
banana bread or different ways to create
banana bread or always just coming up
with ways to update the content so we
want to keep our content our blog post
fresh and then we want to include a cta
call to action if we include a call to
action
then that's going to keep somebody
engaged and have them act on your
content so these are
steps to creating high quality content
and so let's look at an example here and
this is a three month old post on
buzzfeed and it's 21 pictures that
restore your faith in humanity so it has
a lot of likes a lot of tweaks and that
means it's engaged people are engaged
when reading that and so if we go and
look at it as an example we could see it
on a buzzfeed here 21 pictures that will
restore your faith in humanity so this
was written back in 2012 again a lot of
engagement but if we look at it we can
see immediately that it's taking into
account third-party sources it's got
some content it's got images it's being
broken up by images we can see there's
call to actions on there in the form of
social so people can go ahead and go
ahead and share it if they like it okay
it includes videos includes images
third-party sources so it's a good post
because listen you know it's engaging
content it's probably answering
somebody's question about humanity and
we could see clearly that look you know
there's a lot of different examples here
from a lot of different sources and we
could take action on this content so not
just video not just images but text as
well and so it's very engaging answers
questions takes into account the
different types of content available so
this is a good post in that regard so
content's updated regularly it's
engaging and it includes sources from
high authority websites some do's and
don'ts on the content so take into
account the best practices i mentioned
about creating high quality content
answer those questions that the end user
wants to hear you know because that
likely is going to be their search and
so you want to be able to respond to the
end user that's part of creating high
quality content different types of
content i.e in the form of infographics
or videos or text or images you can add
images from public domain sites you can
be relatable and use examples to clarify
points just like the buzzfeed article
simplify complex words don't use
sophisticated language talk to your
audience as if you they were standing
right in front of you and use bullet
points to exemplify your examples your
points so some do's the don'ts obviously
don't lift content we don't want to lift
content from another website so that's
plagiarism so we want to have our own
unique content we also don't want to
take images from other websites and so
if you do happen to find an image that
works for your post and it's on somebody
else's website ideally that's not a good
situation but if you do happen to do
that then always give credit to the
website okay so if you took it from
xyz.com
creditxyz.com for the image and even put
a link back but ideally you don't want
to take images from other websites just
as much as you don't want to take copy
you don't want to take images use your
own imagery and content but if you don't
have imagery then you can always go to
stock photography there are plenty of
websites out there where you can sign up
for a subscription like
adobe stock images as an example you can
sign up for an account and in some cases
you can sign up for free account and use
stock imagery okay don't give less
information to your audience give them
to your audience what they deserve which
is the information they're looking for
they're looking for the best banana
bread recipes give them the best banana
bread recipes incorporate your own
images break it up with titles give them
a good quality piece of content that
they're going to be able to engage with
and so if you put long paragraphs in
your content then it's going to be less
engaging so try to avoid those long
paragraphs remember shorten up the
paragraphs keep the language simple add
in images answer those questions use
third-party credible sources but write
it in your own words and you should be
on your way to creating good quality
content okay so now that we've talked
about high quality content in order to
get your pages ranked high on google
search let's turn our attention to
optimizing on page elements and discuss
some website level factors that are both
going to help you rank high on google
search so
let's just do an overview of what we're
talking about when we talk about on-page
elements and website level factors so
optimizing on page elements include a
number of different things but primarily
we're going to focus in on meta tags
also known as meta description tags
header tags also known as title tags and
urls so those are just some of the
on-page elements we want to be able to
optimize using relevant keywords in
order to rank high on google search we
also want to
take a look at some website factors that
will affect our ranking on google search
they include website architecture having
a secure website having a site map and
taking a look at page speed so all of
those are some of the website factors we
need to take into account in order to
rank high on google search so title tag
and meta description together are
considered
meta tags so both play an important role
in ranking high on google so we want to
be able to write unique title and
descriptions for each page on our
website when i say unique that means the
title and the meta description need to
be different for every page on the
website and so if you're not quite sure
what a title tag and a meta description
tag is if you go to search and just type
in any particular search query the title
tag is what's going to show up here and
bold and then the description is going
to show up below it below the url and
that's going to describe the page so
both of these meta tags are important
because it describes what your page is
all about and that's what google uses in
the search results pages so we want to
be able to pay attention to the length
of our meta tags so if we go back to our
search results pages met title tags are
generally 60 65 characters meta
description tags are generally 160
characters so anything really longer
than that then what's gonna happen is
the
meta description tag or the title tag
will get truncated and so if we look
here for example we can see all of the
title tags here fit the 65 character
limit but if you run over the character
count on meta description then google is
going to truncate the copy so you want
to stay within your parameters in order
to avoid getting your content truncated
and so the other thing when we're
writing title meta description tags we
want to minimize keyword repetition so
if we're optimizing for keyword we don't
want to necessarily just plug that
keyword into the title tag and meta
description multiple times we want to
make sure our title tags and meta
descriptions are naturally written so if
somebody's typing for banana bread
recipe with dried figs you know we want
to have a nice title tag into this
description that is going to get
somebody to respond
based on their need and so we definitely
want to avoid keyword repetition but we
want to be able to use that keyword in
the title tag because if you remember
from the earlier segment when we did the
all in title syntax to find out exactly
how many competitors were using that
particular keyword well we obviously
want to use that keyword in the title
tag because again the title tag is an
important factor when it comes to search
engine results so we want to use the
keyword but we want to avoid stuffing or
using it repetitively in our title tag
and our meta description we want the
title tag and the meta description to
describe the page sound natural but also
be engaging because the point is we want
people to click on our link and go to
our website from search engines so title
tags with numbers tend to result in
higher click-through rates this is
according to mods so for example
if you just put in a title tag that says
learn digital marketing well that may
work but if you put a number in there
like five easy ways to learn digital
marketing that might get somebody to
click on your link and go to your
website so having questions in your meta
tags can also increase your
click-through rate for example if you
just put learn the importance of first
page rankings not too bad but again
generic but if you put it into the
formal question how to rank number one
on google it's more action oriented it's
gonna get somebody to resonate with the
question that they have and that may be
their query how to rank number one on
google and so these techniques will help
you get higher click-through rates and
so according to backlinko
title tag with a keyword can improve
site ranking so remember we want to
include that keyword in the title tag
even though we only have
characters we want to include that
keyword but we want to avoid stuffing
the keyword in there we want to again
make the title tag action oriented maybe
with the number maybe as a question with
the keyword in there once naturally not
easy to do
but that's the beauty of seo if you can
follow these best practices and write a
good title tag then the chances of you
improving in your search results are
going to be greater so having only one
h1 tag in your post is going to be good
so remember when somebody clicks on a
link so let's say they do find a title
tag engaging and they click on this this
link here and they go to that website
you know you want to start out with
having that particular h1 tech because
the h1 tag especially with the keyword
in it is going to signal to google hey
we're organizing our page and because
it's an h1 tag it's important we're
structuring the page according to best
practices so having only one h1 tag in
your post is definitely helpful having
multiple tags h tags in your post help
organize the page a lot better so we
want to add that targeted keyword in
that tag and your header tag should be
relevant to the content so if we go back
to our example of the using dried figs
with banana breads well the title says
california fig banana bread and remember
the last segment when we're talking
about high quality content we'll look no
further than including a video into our
content so not only will this video help
keep the engagement high but it breaks
up the monotony of the page and it's
from a third party source so it adds
credibility to the page so adding a
videos based on the last segment of high
quality content definitely helps with
ranking high on google search so
following hierarchical structure that
means putting those h tags in there h2
tags help break up the content and we
want to avoid repetition of h1 tags on
your different web pages of your site
meaning don't just put the same h1 tag
with the same keyword in it and keeping
it blase we want to make those h1 tags
exciting to read but also used
appropriately to break up the content so
remember all white hat techniques we
want to avoid hidden texts we want to
avoid stuffing keywords we want things
to be natural we don't want things to be
forced and your h1 tag should be 20 to
70 characters don't make long h1 tags so
if we go back to our page example a
short sweet tag here california fake
banana bread it's relevant to the
content it's short sweet and breaks up
the monotony of the content and more
importantly and again any content you
have on the page should always answer
the user's intent remember people are
using search to answer questions find
information our content should be able
to answer that for them so according to
john muller senior webmaster trends
analyst at google header tags would
definitely help google for rankings in
the search results so we want to use
header tags so when it comes to urls we
want to use hyphens and avoid
underscores so if we look at this url
here this uses hyphens fig and banana
bread so it's all broken up with hyphens
that's a best practice remember
canonical urls a canonical url signals
to google this is the original content
so we want to use original content and
if you have multiple sources of content
out there on say different websites we
want to use a canonical tag to signal to
google this is the original content
please index this content and that
doesn't hurt to use a favicon url
meaning a small icon
it helps to break up the monotony and
help your url stand out we can add
targeted keywords in the url so again
looking at the url here i could see
we're using targeted keyword as part of
the url structure vegan banana bread and
notice the h1 tag is fake banana bread
so it's all consistent and it flows
naturally urls that are no longer
existing then we want to be able to set
up a redirect for those urls meaning a
301 redirect is a server response for
google that says hey google this page is
no longer available but we permanently
redirected it to this page which is now
available so that's what a 301 redirect
does it helps signal to google and all
the other search engines that if the
page is no longer there that's fine
you're just going to go to this page
this is the page that's permanently
there now and another thing we want to
do here is if you have mobile urls you
want to include those in the sitemap and
we're going to hit on that in just a
minute but all urls should be mobile
friendly as well as desktop friendly
meaning take into account those best
practices keep your url short use
hyphens put the keyword in that url and
make it easy to understand want to avoid
capital letters in the urls the urls are
case sensitive so go lowercase you
should always go lowercase from the url
readable urls again the rule of thumb
here is if you understand what the url
is then google is going to understand
what the url is so the shorter the url
the easier it is to read the easier it
is to read the better chance you have to
rank high on google search so according
to backlink 2 urls that are shorter
definitely definitely help you rank so
we want to be able to shorten those urls
keep them short and sweet don't make
them long and unreadable so those are
some on optimized ways or on-page
elements that help you optimize now we
want to look at some website level
factors that will help you optimize and
rank high on google search so good site
structure provides better crawling for
search engine bots and what do we mean
by that well we mean having your site
organized in a fashion that google's
gonna be able to find all the pages so
what do we mean by that create a logical
hierarchy structure so if you're selling
shoes you know you're going to have a
home page break the structure up into
men's shoes women's shoes children's
shoes then under men's shoes you could
have it by brand it could be nike puma
adidas on the women's side it could be
nike puma adidas on the child side it
could be nike puma adidas and so you
want to keep the structure flow in a
hierarchy do we want to balance the
amount of subcategories within each
category so the men's if it has nike
puma adidas the women should have nike
puma adidas and so you want to code your
site navigation and css or html meaning
we want to be able to use something that
google is going to be able to index so
most sites are built in html and that's
what google likes to index they like to
index something that they could take
back to their servers and then more
importantly build a comprehensive
structure for internal linking so
internal links mean that if you're on a
site you should have natural links
pointing to other pages on your website
so to keep the flow going and we don't
want to have unnatural inbound things
you always want to have natural internal
links to keep the flow of the user going
from one page to the other so here i can
see as an example all the ingredients in
this recipe well this has an internal
link to another page on our site and
this happens to link to a page where
somebody can buy the ingredients so it's
a natural internal link so john doherty
of credo has claimed that one of the
biggest changes that he can make in
fixing the credo website is architecture
so for example in credo john dougherty
has increased the organic sessions by 74
and pages by per session by 41
just by changing the site architecture
so you'd be surprised by changing the
site architecture what that will do to
engagement and so let's turn our
attention to secure versus non-secure so
what we mean by that is securing your
site we want to make it sure that
compliant with certain protocols and so
if we go back here we can see that this
particular site is compliant it is
secure
https means it has a secure license
meaning the site is secure so google
likes secure versus non-secure so
non-secure would be http so we want
https
as our protocol and what that means is
just enabling ssl certificates and that
means when you enable an ssl certificate
that means your domain or your protocol
is going to be turned to https so google
prefers sites that are secure versus
non-secure so if you use hsts
as a protocol that adds an extra layer
of security over the https and
hsts prevents cookie hijacking so adding
multiple layers of security always helps
in my opinion if you have an http
website a non-secure website you should
look into
buying an ssl certificate getting your
sites flipped over to https because
what's going to happen is your url
structure is going to change when your
url structure changes google's going to
recognize that because they're going to
index your site and when they index your
site they're going to see those secure
urls and that's going to work favorably
in your favor and help you rank higher
on google search so websites using
secure or https
have a higher chance of ranking higher
so https is a ranking signal because
google indexes those pages so let's also
talk about site maps so sitemap is one
of the most important ways to improve
your website ranking why well because
sitemaps are a way to organize all your
urls into one file so we're basically
going to
prioritize all our web pages in a
sitemap so if you go to any particular
website and you type in sitemap xml
you're likely going to see all the pages
on your website so usually the site map
is located in the root directory so if i
type in
sitemap.xml i'm going to be able to see
all the pages in my root directory and i
can also prioritize them i can also
alert google as to how often they change
and every page is going to have a date
stamp associated with it so google can
actually see how often it changes so
remember we want our content to be
updated frequently so content's not
updated frequently or it's not fresh
then google is going to see that site
that date stamp that last modification
down so we want to be able to make sure
content's updated frequently we want to
let google know that we changed it
frequently and we want to be able to
prioritize our pages let google know hey
these pages are important to us so all
that can be set up in a sitemap we want
to be able to add canonical versions of
urls in the sitemaps so we want to be
able to add all our original urls in our
sitemap and so we always want to build
dynamic urls sitemaps for larger
websites and what i mean by dynamic urls
that means that if i look at this
sitemap and we're always adding content
let's just say in the form of a blog
well guess what we want those pages to
be added to the sitemap as they're
published so as we add pages to the blog
or to the site then they should
automatically be added to the sitemap
and so in effect what's going to happen
is we're going to be able to see the
site map grow with more urls when the
sitemap grows with more urls then that
means then google's going to index more
pages they're going to index more fresh
pages so they're going to be able to get
those pages that are just published
quicker so that's the whole idea behind
dynamic site maps is we want to be able
to capture all the urls just as they're
published and we want to be able to
maintain our site maps and so i would
always recommend a dynamic sitemap but
you can always create your own sitemap
just by going to a tool called xml
sitemap so if i just type in xml
sitemaps
into google search here i can see xml
sitemaps generator and i can be able if
i have a small website just create a
free and simple
sitemap on my own when xml sitemaps
creates it or your platform creates a
dynamic sitemap either way the sitemap's
going to sit in the root directory and
then what we want to do in turn is let
google know where that sitemap is so in
search console we want to be able to
submit the sitemap so you're going to
add the sitemap you're going to let
google know where it is it should be in
the root directory and it should be
called
sitemap.xml and when you do that google
is going to be able to take those urls
and index them so we could see we
submitted 528 urls google index 521. so
one thing about urls here is when we
create a sitemap we're putting all your
urls in there we do not add no index
urls in your sitemap and what that means
is that any url we don't want google to
index we're just going to exclude from
the sitemap okay so we want google to
take all the urls we want indexed and
put them in the sitemap so according to
edgy using sitemaps for seo can increase
your website's visibility and help you
get indexed why because what you're in
fact doing is taking all your urls that
you want indexed you're telling google
how often they're modified you're
telling google which ones are important
and you're submitting that to google and
so google is going to be able to take
all those urls quicker index them
quicker and when they're indexed quicker
you can get ranked quicker and when you
get rank quicker you can get traffic
quicker so that's the whole idea behind
site maps so let's turn our attention to
page speed now so when the last factors
for our website besides architecture
making it secure and adding site maps is
want to take a look at how quick our
pages load here are some tips in order
to optimize page speed because ideally
the quicker a page loads the more
engaged the user is going to be if it
takes a longer time for the page to load
all the elements of that page then
what's going to happen is the user is
going to get impatient maybe leave the
website all together or go to another
page and so we want to be able to
optimize images so any image that's of
large size in terms of megabytes we want
to be able to optimize that to compress
the image so that's one way to speed up
page speed we want to use a simple
website design you know html with css or
cascading style sheets just a simple
design with simple hierarchy and website
navigation structure so nothing fancy
nothing complex just a simple website
design with optimized images we want to
leverage browser caching and we want to
upgrade the server response time meaning
all your files are sitting on the server
so when somebody goes to web page the
server is serving up all of those files
the images the text etc and so we want
the server to respond as quick as
possible so when it comes to page speed
we can look at the factors affecting
page speed in google analytics so if i
go to google analytics and i go under
behavior and i go under site speed and i
go to overview i'm going to be able to
see what my average load time is for my
site and ideally we want our pages to
load as quick as possible so that means
anything under four seconds anything
four seconds or higher and it's likely
the end user is going to leave the page
there's a correlation be between page
load time and bounce rate and so what
google actually does is give you speed
suggestions so if we do have a page that
loads slow we can just go to speed
suggestions and google analytics and we
go to speed suggestions then google's
going to be able to tell us hey this
particular page load fast this potential
page loads slow and if it loaded slow
why is it loading slow so here we could
see
the home page of the example is loaded
on average of seven seconds well if we
look here they're going to give us some
suggestions so if i click on this page
speed suggestions it's going to load a
report and a tool called page speed
insights and basically what it's then
going to do after it's done running is
is going to tell me all the ways in
which i can optimize my pages not only
for
desktop but also for mobile so here i
can see for desktop or for mobile i can
look at some ways in which i can
optimize it to increase page speed for
example sizing my images properly server
response time reducing my server
response time avoiding multiple page
redirect so there's a lot of
opportunities that we can do to speed up
page load time and all that's found in
page speed insights and all that's found
within google analytics so remember
optimizing code minimizing redirects
optimizing your images upgrading your
server response and all of those are
factors and so again you can go into
analytics page speed insights and you
can see exactly what google is
recognizing as what's lowering or
slowing down your page load time so
google takes site speed as one of the
most important ranking factors why
because they're going to rank pages not
only with high quality content that are
relevant to the keyword queries but they
want those pages to have a good user
experience so if somebody clicks on the
page then the user should be able to see
that content fairly quickly and so
that's why it's such an important factor
so the quicker your pages load the
chances of you ranking higher are going
to be better so according to web
performance today walmart as an example
experienced declining conversions so
what they did was looked at their page
speed and when they looked at their page
speed you'd be surprised what that did
just increasing it from one to four
seconds or decreasing it basically
increase conversion so there's always
going to be a correlation between how
quick a page loads and how engaged the
user is because if it's users engaged
they're gonna stay on the site and if
they stay on the site then their chances
of converting are going to be higher so
just even one to two seconds increase in
page load load time will make a world of
difference in terms of engagement and
conversions let's turn our attention to
off-site engagement so previously we
talked about on-page elements and
website factors that affect our rankings
for search results but we also need to
turn our attention away from our website
meaning what we do on our website and
turn our attention what we can do for
our website off our website and onto
other websites so that's off site
engagement and so let's look at an
example so that ice cream recipes blog
thanks rob with that we've reached the
end of this complete seo tutorial i hope
you guys enjoyed this video do like and
share it thank you for watching and stay
tuned for more from simply learn
[Music]